i'm wearing headphones just for you
bobby
i have a bone to pick with you oh jesus
christ what's fucking new what do you
mean what
so can i just pick a bone
maybe sure they pick a bone
so the other day i was at the
conversation i know you have 500
podcasts but podcasts can start with
some kind of formal intro like it's
bobby lee is here you guys you know him
from
harold and kumar but you know sometimes
movies you know they do the the opening
credits like maybe 20 minutes in
like 8 24 we'll do that or whatever
that's to be that okay that's not 20
minutes let's not be a studio film let's
be artsy about it okay okay cool yeah
what do you think what do you guys think
yeah this is definitely art go ahead
we'll go start you know what no no
please so um
i was at the store i was talking to my
friend
the comedy store what story the comedy
store jeff harris i'm in the park and
and we're um
i'm talking with the young comic from
new york
and you walk by and i'm like i want to
impress
you know i mean this young comic from
new york that i know whitney cummings
sure so i turn on i go what's up and you
just keep fucking walking sure to the
back sure where that wall is right you
don't see hello nothing right so now i'm
blushing
right so when asians blush we turn
purple
we don't go pink
and so um i'm blushing
and then finally you kind of go let's
out you're like you know i mean you
can't come up and then
by the way didn't this girl also have a
wine stand on her face that's right
that's what you can't
say
but that's the bone i want to pick with
you is i was watching you meet her and
you stared too much at her mole
or a birthmark okay you like i when you
meet someone like that you were like
literally coming on this podcast telling
me i looked at someone's weinstein
that's the only reason why i'm on here i
think it's rude so it wasn't that i
ignored you yeah when you see a guy with
no hand maybe if you had a wine stain on
your face i would actually pay attention
to you
maybe you should get one yeah is it like
a mark like here's what i'll say i i
mean i'm sure we have to cut this out
why oh we're not i think for me
hilarious she's hilarious yeah and i'm
sure she acknowledges it in her set yeah
as someone whose face is ever evolving
and who every time i go to the comics
where people look at my face like what's
happening here now
i'm fine with staring at people's faces
mine gets stared out a lot it gets
googled a lot yeah uh but i there is
this thing now where women like contour
their makeup very
hard
and so i think i it was like at night
and i was just trying to understand what
i was looking at
but the fact that you clocked me
clocking it says so much more i was just
trying to orient my face says so much
about me
well you you okay this is what happened
you were staring at her wine staying too
long and you felt shame for it i walked
up i didn't know this person i met her
for the first time and i was like
wine stain got it uh harvey weinstein
should be calling that
and then you
now have been you were watching me
hoping i would fuck up and you did she
probably looked at my face way longer
than i looked at her trying to figure
out what she was dealing with
okay
well that being said i apologize
i apologize do you see the way you told
that story it was going in the direction
of whitney was gonna ignore me and was
being shitty and rude
and i was trying to impress this comic
yeah okay and now we ended up just
hurting her feelings by doing this
podcast about no no first of all i don't
think we're hurting her feelings because
she is funny yeah she has a skill set
yeah and um she's beautiful as well
beautiful face beautiful everything
and um i don't know why are you doing
this
by the way can we talk about the
the wine state of a tattoo that's still
on your arm that hasn't been finished
yet okay that's rude i've said that i've
stared at a really long time because i
think it's ugly all right but this right
here is a reminder it looks like the nbc
logo
well i was getting this done when i was
on an nbc show and then they canceled it
so i didn't finish it is that really not
the truth
if you were gonna be on an nbc show you
should have noticed me
soon thereafter i have another one my
back is a cb and that's it
[Laughter]
so um i i've i i i've been seeing a
psychiatrist for the first time
by the way this is can i just tell you
oh i might get too hard
someone that is a professional comedian
podcaster that just shows up like the
way you do is such a dream why because i
don't have to do anything
oh i'm sorry in a good way like do you
see how he just come he's like that
story he's right he's like this like
like it's just a dream i've had guests
online a couple
i want to name names but um good comics
great comics sure and you go what's
going on
good and that's it
and that's the worst guess you can have
it's just it's like pulling teeth and
then and then when someone comes on and
doesn't say a lot or doesn't have like a
game plan or whatever and then you end
up having to pick up the slack and
everyone's like why do you talk so much
why didn't you let the guests speak yeah
yeah yeah so the psychiatrist you're
going to is this a new one because the
old one should be no i have released no
i have a great therapist okay she's
great but i've never seen a psychiatrist
how long have you been with the
therapist for years okay she's the best
and um
why because the relapse i'm joking
it's like you know when people that have
made no progress keep telling you about
their therapist and you're like i feel
like
yeah yeah like i feel like other people
should be able to weigh in on if your
therapist is good or not to see it not
just you yeah i mean i know a lot of
people that go yeah i'm working on
myself but they don't really hate that
because a lot of people like the
therapist because their therapist allows
them to just come in and complain and
re-embed their own trauma and that's why
they like them because
the therapists that don't call them out
on their shit
no i prefer i always have aa sponsors
and therapists that are harsh on me
because i can't like for instance the
last rehab i went to which is a couple
of weeks ago
they every time i would exaggerate
or i no and i would tell a joke they
would go
stop we're not doing that right that's
huge and they know that that's my way of
deflecting that's my ml
minimizing self-replicating yeah and if
i say you know i'm a fat ugly guy
they're like no you're actually um an
attractive person you know i mean like
so and then i go gotcha sexual
harassment call hr fuck that we were
suing this whole fucking rehab
so um yeah i usually have harsh people
because i i don't listen to anything out
anyone else that's that's what i need in
our relationship i feel like is very
poignant oddly and deep because we're
able to give each other really harsh
feedback and we don't
um it doesn't make it doesn't push us
away from each other it makes well
that's what i love about you
and hate no i i strictly only love
because the thing is is you're the only
one that um
and you and marin marin will do the same
thing like stop that like if i'm like if
i'm doing something where it's like um
i'm either deflecting or i'm you know
the thing that i do when i have a good
set and then you go good set and i go
that wasn't a good sign
you and so you're calling me a liar no
you and mark are
you and mark are always like stop that
because but you know that we're not
doing it from a place of dismissing
we're doing it for a place of like oh
you can break that pattern or that habit
so basically you and i i feel like our
we went from like friends to like
siblings when i was first able to go
like stop doing that thing
before you would go on stage i really
appreciate it yeah that's all i wanted
it's just like when someone calls us out
on our shit the emotional version of you
have food in your teeth yeah of the like
i know you i love you i do the same
thing you're doing
but you don't need to emotionally cut
yourself around me yeah when someone's
able to do that in a way that isn't like
trying to embarrass you in front of
people or doesn't do it publicly it's
more of just like a one-on-one thing
yeah
but it's also you you know when you you
and i know you when you rise in the
business and stuff people treat you a
little differently at clubs and stuff
and then also the new friends that you
get
it's based on a different what they
perceive who you are or whatever and
it's like not really that real right
right but every once in a while you'll
meet somebody like yourself and
i mean i would have to say that you're
bigger than i am you just didn't you
feel like you're trying to be fat
but anyway my point is is that um thank
you
but i i'm seeing this psychiatrist and
um
she said i think you have h well many
psycho because when you go to these um
treatment centers they have
psychiatrists too i just got a second
opinion and they were and she was
basically you have
adhd
okay
do you have the touchy thingy or no
where you have to touch things three
times
so so this is this is i'm so glad you're
here
um
we what are you doing
i'm listening oh but why are you leaning
that way we framed your
camera perfectly and you've so far sat
on the back and you've leaned out
there's no way you can get my light we
have rigged this in a way
you've worked with a lot of malignant
narcissists as soon as i started doing
my coverage you like leaned
away yeah um no but i just to just give
everybody contacts like you know i know
you talk about this like publicly like
you've been going through a lot we both
have been going through like i just say
one last thing real quick
imagine me
tv cameras in the fucking this is like
high tech that's for teleprompters go
ahead so what do you guys read your ads
off what a sticky note iphone yeah
insane
insane good but by the way the the
quality of ad of the fact that blue chew
or manscaped or any of these people pay
you guys reading off your barely reading
it out off your phone is it is the it is
shocking to me
as a minority i expect more from you
you have single-handedly destroyed the
model minority stereotype can i ask you
a random question about your vagina uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah please because
i don't ever want to see it
i know not that it's grizzly or a
monstrous monstrosity but i'm just
saying that
i'm sure it's normal and very christian
looking slightly cumbersome yeah yeah
but um you know it's funny because i
view you only
as a friend sure there's no sexual
nothing this is
your this is the meanest thing you've
ever said why are you trying to hurt me
i'm not trying to hurt you i'm sure it's
beautiful okay i'm sure is any vagina
beautiful or is there anything you said
jazz hands i don't think jazz hands you
know i mean when they're like hey
i'm here i don't like that you know i
mean i like it when it's tucked you know
what i mean and that's just my own
problem
not tucked but like a little flower a
little flower's fine okay what kind of
flower are we talking a peony we talking
an impatient are we talking about
because of the ukraine thing sunflower
the sunflower is more like a like a like
a honeysuckle or like a morning glory
yeah yours is more like those traps
what do you call those venus
a guacamole trap for some reason i don't
know why because they're like those big
green things yes okay so is it is it
sexual harassment or is it weird
if i asked like a friend who's just a
girl because i've seen all my
guy friends as penis as a comic you know
what i mean where
wouldn't we everywhere
yeah yeah oh the pittsburgh can probably
be everywhere i mean
everywhere on a roller coaster you know
i mean it doesn't yeah it's improv yes
it is yeah yeah yeah so um
but it's like i have female friends
that i don't have any sexual desires or
anything as this is a friend i would
just love to see their genitals that's
all sure sure but it's because of the
climate and stuff you can't ask i've
never asked and it's weird right because
of the client because it's the climate
it's hot and stuffy down there it's too
hot for me to show you my pussy the
climate right now is just it's too hot
outside
um i feel like i've shown you you've
seen my boobs i feel like you have yeah
yeah pretty good not the new ones you
have new ones
no
i don't think i've seen i don't think
i've dicks are easier to whip out and
put back in the vaginas like by the time
you show it to someone as a joke you've
like caught a disease right it's an open
wound like you can't they they're dick
like that's my whole thing when i was
like he just like pulled his dick out
it's like it's a very easy thing to do
to pull your dick out yeah but i'm not
asking to see the lips
i'm just asking to see just the
entry part
you know how you see like a beautiful
house
you'd love to see what's inside but it's
like something you just drive by you
want to do like a drive-by and just see
the shutters that's right you just want
to okay but i want to see what style it
is
to how close you can be to a platonic
friend of the opposite sex if you
haven't seen their genitals yeah it is
it is wild because it's like if i don't
know what you're working with it is hard
to advise you on many things so like for
example i remember a girlfriend of mine
who uh um
like you know i'm just gonna say her
name fuck it stephanie zimbari uh we
were like were
girlfriends she opened for me on the
road for a while a good friend and we're
like touring together and she's like
having all these like guy problems and
this and this and then one time we were
in soul cycle and i saw her completely
naked and i was like
wait had i known this was your body i
would have given you different advice
this whole time
what do you mean like do not text him
back you are totally i just hadn't seen
her like fully make it and it's like she
just has the most incredible body like
most incredible like tits like incred
like she had this like like pubes
everywhere i was like bitch you like
she had pubes everywhere
i was like you know i just mean like
when i saw her naked i was like you
don't need to play any games with any
guy they should be i just hadn't seen
what she was working with right
and i know that sounds insane
it was emily the first time i saw emily
i've known her for eight years and then
i all of a sudden we discovered that
she's got giant like
big pendulous naturals we discovered we
all discovered we discovered at the same
time
i would have dealt with you completely
differently these past eight years
knowing that you had these like honkers
i was like you're a bully now like i
used to feel like like you were allowed
to have low self-esteem but now that
i've seen your tits like how dare you
you know like so it's like it's stuff
like that i if i it's like when you find
out when your guy friends has like a
giant dick
you're like
i i like it just changed
it changes the way you advise them you
view them
i was okay with paulie shore until i saw
his penis you see a vagina dick it's not
just giant it it does this is it the
size of a weasel
it it you know it's like a you know how
you go to magic mountain there's that
one ride you're like nope you know it's
like that nope yep and it's so veiny
by the way can you put i want to do a
master class with comedians where they
think they're making sense but it's just
more confusing
so like you're trying to you're like you
know how like when you go on a roller
coaster it's like no
let me explain bitter about paulie's
dick then okay all right so let's see
this is the dick joining explain who
polly sure is first
for the listeners if you love son-in-law
i like that one um biodome not so much
but anyway so this is a penis right no
no
no no all right so um let me just draw
it okay okay so um
isn't it weird that we know each other
really well but i've never seen your
handwriting yeah so um
okay that is a penis oh okay by the way
you can tell that bobby's uh uh podcasts
tiger belly and bad friends are very
highly viewed on youtube because he only
mimes he doesn't there's no audio
experience i try to fucking do it with a
hand man that's not an audio experience
you have to explain what about just
someone just listening okay sorry our
our demo is not only youtube trolls like
yours all right so anyway um
i don't know how to explain this but
this is a standard you have the palest
fan base of anyone i know every time
someone comes up to me looking like they
have scurvy after one of my shows i'm
like that's a tiger belly fan okay okay
all right that's rude that's work nights
okay so here so that's a regular penis
that's not a regular piece
wait yeah so this is it
that's my actual size i just drew a
photo of a penis and this and he fully
goes to the world thinking this is the
shape of a penis i don't know how to
help you standing on the ball yeah
the ball okay this is an erect penis to
be clear and why did you add wrinkles
like why does it have crow's feet
okay now you're drawing what is that i
can i can draw a picture of my vagina if
you want me to okay and i can drop your
shirt what penises i don't know
i don't know okay paulie's dick is a
siamese twins
why does it is it's a it's twisted okay
okay like a ride why is it a centos i
have no idea i never asked him why did
it go to some wars is there a purple
heart i didn't ask him that so because
it's just been through a lot so you're
not saying it's big you're saying it's
been it's it's um sinewy it's also it's
not okay it is very thick and very long
and very big okay very thick very long
it's like an average black man's dick i
think
copy that but why is it all twisted up i
think it's all the wars but can i say
about the veins
okay every vein that's in the penis is
you can see what did you go to because
i'd like to i'd like to write a yelp
from you
i think i think we need to go back
did we do 20 did we through 30 days i
think we went wonder okay
so this is paulie's dick is he cool with
you talking about this yeah and how what
what context have you seen his dick in
many contacts okay have you seen it hard
no that's the scary part see that's the
thing about all you guys you've seen
each other's dick but not hard but then
that's a different relationship
you know i mean if my friend you want to
see my dick and it's hard it just
changes the relationship right there
it's like dude don't call me for a
couple years can i ask you about
something what is up with guys that like
to have threesomes that are friends
i've done that i know have you nope oh
it's the if you it's the what
oh god i'm getting emotional
i'm literally
i know a lot of guys that are friends
and they'll have threesomes with girls
together and i just don't see how that's
not awkward if i saw someone having sex
with emily i would kill myself
okay and her too you're so everyone
would die
your mind is closed friend my mind is
and your heart is closed copy that yeah
in every aspect i hope it is true
that's something i've worked very hard
at
you have to once in your life have sex
with three comedians with one of my
friends you have to do it with ugly
people like me
guys ugly guys the women is beautiful
okay so so then so anyone
anyone that's talking about some of you
they already know that that you think
they're ugly no no but then the guy has
to be ugly but why would you want to
fuck isn't the whole point of a
threesome is that everyone's hot and you
want to fuck everyone there when you're
a canadian right the options are like
small
right there's because by the way do you
think this is small
the whole thing is just me it's not
something
guy comics i would that are good looking
are not a lot jezelnik
right you got jeff dye uh-huh cutie
jeff dye is cutie okay right there's
that one guy from
canada that i love guys talk about other
guys that are hot it's like my i love
watching football games with guys solely
because they'll be like he's handsome
he's good looking guy yeah like i love
hearing this yeah i love to admit it too
but um but this is fascinating because i
think that any guy who is like funny and
confident and on stage i can fall in
love with and i think that's handsome
the number one thing every woman says
about what they want in a man is sense
of humor that's so not true it it that
you're gonna make me angry
you know the worst thing was even as a
young comic when i lived in la jolla
okay right
i have how do you think you got kalila
because she has that jawline
those cheekbones yeah yeah fuck you
women do like a sense of humor okay fine
some women
some fucking women all right but i'm
just saying i as a young guy i was
always funny funnier than everyone else
right and i would have girl
you mean before you got into comedy yeah
but yeah comparatively to other the best
comics in the world i'm okay
but anyway you are no fuckhead you know
that i think you're one of those people
i can follow anyone on planet earth and
that's all i know if you put your hand
in my camera one more time yeah
sorry i apologize your show all right
so what i i
had up to my train of thought and you oh
so oh yeah you're running a train no no
in a threesome so no but i'm gonna i'm
gonna get to that in a second but um
this is like a myth conversation when
you when you're on math i've never done
math oh well i've done adderall yeah
i know but real math like i've
when you're with two guys and you're
doing math you write down what you want
to talk about so you don't forget that's
what i do all the time just i don't know
normally i was i was because i finished
my fucking thing in my early 20s right i
was always good there was this girl i
can't name her name right and she was
and i had a crush on her and i made a
move she goes i just want to be friends
just say it it's fine we're we can speak
freely here you just talked about where
you were
so three months later
she meets another guy she's like
i can't wait to meet you meet my friend
my new boyfriend ralph and i go yeah
she's like he's hilarious like you and
then you meet the guy and he's so not
funny
he's like yeah and women are always i've
had 20 experiences like that right where
someone says this guy's exactly like you
his personality or they're just funny or
you're going to get along they're super
funny and then you go no no not funny at
all in any way the girls version of that
is oh my god my friend looks exactly
like you and you're like oh here we go
this is going to hurt my feelings and
they show you a picture of just like an
actual sweet potato yeah so let's go
let's go to the threesome with three
sorry i was drawing my vagina it says
i'm i need to does not look like that
that does not look like my vagina
there's no you're right you're right
yeah yeah yeah that is not yeah that
looks like an uh or a pegalone yeah it's
more like this anyway um
so when you're having
hooking up with three comics in a room
threesomes like there's you will laugh
harder than you've ever learned in your
life but i don't but that's not sex
isn't funny to me it's embarrassing and
the idea of a commit being naked around
other comedians
like
when you're supposed to be like
feel like as a woman having sex i just
feel like it's too vulnerable i don't
want to be vulnerable around comedians
you know this is my whole thing about
how i don't think i'll ever be able to
get married because how am i going to
say like sincere vows in front of
comedians
i'm i won't yeah i literally i've been
engaged i think my engagement was broken
off because i started thinking about the
vows i was just like how am i going to
sincerely talk of like
open my heart to somebody and cry in
front of comedians
but having sex with somebody oh because
that happens
three other people are different it's
like you know nfl players they still go
home and play madden
why madam madden madden john madden it's
a video game about a language barrier
bobby yeah i don't know how to say
maddox
but i would rather play madame quite
frankly madden
so you as you can you know sex is
different you know masturbation is
different than having sex with a loved
one having sex with a bunch of comics is
different than having sex with a loved
one it's different you go into it with a
different mentality you don't go i'm
going to come you go i'm going to laugh
my ass off but that's not for sex that's
that's you go is that because you we've
been robbed of the ability to enjoy
comedy because we're comics that you
have to go to sex for your humor yeah
but dude i'm not a i don't think sex i
don't believe in sex being funny like
when i go to porn now and i see all
these like funny sketches where someone
is roller skating they trip and fall on
a dick and it's like oh like yeah i love
lucy of porn i don't think i i don't get
that yeah but sex is serious to me
but imagine you know let's say you me
let's give you a third comment brian
scalaro because if you laugh at what
here's here's what it is if you laugh at
a woman during sex i'm not sexy or pre
like i have walked out before in like
lingerie like the first time i was able
to have money and i'm like with a guy
and i buy lingerie and i put it on and i
i gotta get it wrong or whatever and
it's just like i look like i'm like
david carradine hanging myself with a
fishnet or whatever and the guy was
dating laughs yeah and that was like the
most humiliating it left like such a
mark the idea of a woman trying to be
sexy and someone laughing yeah is too
traumatic okay
but imagine this your language when you
had threesomes with a guy a comedian and
a girl did she like that you were just
laughing at her pussy
yeah because she was laughing at my dick
first
but like why would you want to have sex
because
listen i pulled my penis out and she
burst you popped it out yeah i popped it
up but she burst into
like holding her side
going on the ground and just convulsing
laughing which made me and the other
which means the movies had not kicked
yet
and you needed to yeah but
i started laughing so hard and my the
other guy comic laughed so hard it's we
spent laughing for 45 minutes and i
think it's still out then you have in
coitus and then we had intercourse later
it was great
you have to try it
but no because we're 50. i guess i'm
realizing that sex for me is more of a
means to an end it's not like a joyful
like let's have fun it's like uh i i
don't
i can't look you in the eye and
apologize for that thing i did wrong so
i guess something you know it's like
it's more of a healing
uh
like chore than it is like a
recreational
hobby well this was 20 years ago and i
don't do that because to me sex i feel
like has so many yeah yeah
there's no if so i love laughing during
sex like what um
uh
like an ex of mine the one of the
hardest times i've ever laughed is when
i told him
like i want you one time during sex to
call me a pig and see if we can get
through without laughing like don't tell
me when you're gonna do it
four months later we're in hong kong
and had had some like weird brandy and
he was like take it you fucking pig and
i we laughed for like three days yeah
yeah it was in the fight that's what i'm
talking about that's hilarious that's
what i'm talking about but it can't be
lols from the jump
i'd be embarrassed okay i'm too scared
to reach his own i'm too sensitive okay
i get insecure
yeah but you know what because i you
know i've gone to deep therapy and i'm
deep therapy
can i tell you what happened to me in
the last couple of months sure did you
know
i
will respond to your texts any minute
yeah do i know what happened to the last
couple months yeah but the last month
did you know like but like i'm a little
over a month ago did you know what
happened
i feel i i i i almost i felt like i was
gonna die
i um i started cop
you're such a fucking asshole
i'm sorry
we now take a break
you're good at that
that was good
why are you just deep throating on an
imaginary dig over there oh cause it has
to be imaginary
once again that's good once again not a
burn once again thank you mom
i hate that
for the self-esteem speaking of thanks
mom this spot podcast is sponsored by
better help if it's not one thing it's
your mother or your whitney better help
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not a
self-help line it's professional therapy
done securely online if you're in a
crisis don't call better help they don't
that's not that's not what they do we'll
put whitney's cell phone number on the
bottom of the screen yeah yeah call call
me for those matters call you should
give you a bigger graces
i'll show you guys
that's a good crisis
i'm in a crisis i'll show you chrysler
well you think that ukraine and russia
okay good point it's i just give you
perspective and convince you that your
crisis isn't that big of a deal that's
genius
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions so you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room as with traditional therapy
i have to say i
the more that we talk about better help
on this podcast people come up to me
and say that it's changed their life
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available betterhelp
wants you to start living a happier life
today special offer for good for you
listeners get ten percent off your first
month at
betterhelp.com you better help yourself
to better help
because look i would like to call
betterhelp uh i don't know does this
count as something that i should call
about i'm dating a man that is nine
years my junior is that how you say it
okay nine years younger than me and i
had a scab uh i have a i have a scab on
the side of my arm and i go i was like
does this look bad he goes oh is that a
liver spot
that's called you should both be single
now that's called emotional abuse that's
called amusement i'm so shocked he said
that he was joking i'm so disappointed
but i can't stop thinking about it and
then he just texted me i was like how
how goes it and he wrote back just
trying to get through this old day how
was the pod
is he attacking you i think maybe
i'm gonna have a talk with him doordash
now look i know i know what you're
thinking
this girl if she is nothing if not wife
material
like
if she made a brisket i would gobble up
look yes am i incredible at making
chicken cordon bleu of course i am that
doesn't mean she wants to can i make a
banana flan in my sleep
but i don't have that kind of time
[Music]
okay i have stuff to do i have myself to
google
okay
that's why i use door dash okay along
with the restaurants you love you can
get groceries
other essential items you can get drinks
snacks and other household items in
under one hour
craving late night ice cream
that was not an innuendo
forget that the one key ingredient for
your dinner
where's the cilantro where's the cordon
oh where's the nutmeg or maybe you just
need to stock up for the week with
doordash get everything in one app with
over three hundred thousand partners you
can support your neighborhood go-to wait
why are you talking about me
just because i've had 300 000 partners
are you trying to shame me oh my god i'd
love to have 300 thousand partners with
over 300 000 partners you can support
your neighborhood go-to's or choose from
your favorite national tr or choose from
your favorite national restaurants like
popeyes chipotle and cheesecake factory
maybe we shouldn't have let her doordash
that mike's heart lemonade earlier
ordering is easy and your items will be
left safely outside your door when you
choose contactless delivery drop-off
easy peasy for a limited time our
listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on their first order of 15
or more when you download the door dash
app and enter code gfy that's 25 off up
to 10 value and zero delivery fees on
your first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
code g f y they'll don't forget that's
code g f y for 25 off your first order
with door dash the subject to change
term supply speaking of
meals cooking
family events where you go with this
easter egg easter's coming up easter's
coming up what a drag and easter you
know how easter you know how easter goes
every year you wait for jesus never
comes never comes
no this is not an ad for blue chew uh
uh yes story of my life once a year
waiting for a man to show up and he
never does
oh jesus
we've decided that this easter we're not
gonna we're not gonna let y'all just
like go to a boozy brunch go home and
watch the tinder swindler
you know and then dm'ing him asking if
he can hang we're not gonna let you make
bad decisions this year we are going to
be live
doing a live podcast april 17th for
easter live easter pop live online
easter egg come on over
we on april 17th are going to be doing a
live
exclusive
online podcast we've never done a live
podcast before for a bunch of reasons
mostly because
anxiety i can't get mostly because panic
attacks at night terrors um and a litany
of other addictions had to be real
we're gonna find a way for me to curl my
hair an hour before the show so i can
actually be here on time and so that my
ocd doesn't completely take over and
sabotage my future so we're gonna try to
do a live
show on easter it's gonna happen you
guys can send picture pictures send your
dick pics
we like feet send photos videos we're
going to answer anything you ask but we
have to be more specific where are they
going to ask it ahead of time or you can
ask we're going to take questions in
advance and live we're going to have i
mean everybody knows what this is that
segora does it everyone does this why
are we explaining the concept of a live
podcast you guys get it i'm just in a
panic okay and so go to momenthouse.com
good for you it's being put on by moment
house you can buy tickets there and you
can buy them now april 17th we'll see
you live online event we can't wait
don't embarrass yourself
this weekend she's talking to herself i
am gonna be
you dressed me today so i'm already
consumed with humiliation
um come see me live if you want to do my
comedy yuck yuck still trying to get
love from my dad dad in portland maine
at the merrill auditorium on march 18th
march 19th i'm in new hampshire colonial
theater march 25th i'm going to be in
new haven connecticut college street
music hall not playing any music about
my shrill voices harmonious
april 1st oop austin texas paramount
theater april 2nd i'm going to be in
dallas march 26th i'm going to be in
albany
whitneycompanies.com i shouldn't have to
read all these things to you because i'm
dyslexic and you all know that and this
is exhausting and i'm going to get lock
draw back to our guest um i knew that um
can we pitch gravestone ideas for
bobby's um so i knew i knew
i knew we're going to talk about some
really heavy shit yeah yeah and
as someone that has been incredibly uh
that loves you like a um
brother that truly considers you family
and someone that's been so worried and
scared and loves you i knew we're going
to talk about this today but
that's why i brought up paulie shore's
dick
a little evidence you know you know
woman with paulie you know that's funny
right right
i opened with a couple you know so yes
and listen we don't have to talk about
the whole fucking time and i just want
to check in with you i would love to
talk about it i just um love you and i'm
cutting tension with thank you silly and
i'm sorry
you almost died we got it all right so
can i
tell you what happened yes so what
happened was i um
when bob died i was still i was so i was
doing like two thousand three thousand
milligrams of edibles a day yeah smoking
24 hours a day and drinking and um by
the time he died you would have built up
today i built up to that because here's
something that i think is just we're
just worth talking about you know as
people that are both in
programs that are both trying to stay
emotionally sober
like i think that you know as someone
that
very publicly i think you saw had
struggled with edibles over the pandemic
uh ruined one of my friends um online
zoom memorials
because i was so high on edibles
that that's
the thing that i can't really take
currently that is my allergy but
you also go in 10 years maybe that'll
change it's one day at a time for now
the edibles don't work for me and as
someone that you know has been you know
sober there is this thing where you go
like okay for now this doesn't work for
me but i maybe in 10 years i'll
experiment with smoking weed or yeah and
you see people who can or can't or but
there is like
that period where you're like i've been
sober for a while let me just try to see
if i could do this like a gentleman now
with all this recovery was that how it
kind of started yeah but also what i
realized through this is i've been told
this by many therapists and and
psychiatrists because i've been doing
two rehabs in the last couple of months
they say that when somebody has ptsd or
extreme trauma and they do weed it does
the adverse effect
right so i became manic
and i become um
i can't eat or sleep so um
but i was smoking cigarettes i mean i've
been smoking since i was 18. so when bob
died i started coughing up chunks of
blood
in my mucus
and it was like dark blood
and all the time and i would send it to
kalila she's a nurse and stuff and just
like am i dying she's like what the fuck
you know stop sending me whitney's nudes
yeah yeah
no she wasn't like is that whitney's
you know i mean period blood you know i
go that's from my lungs you know and
so you know when you're using not
sleeping you're not eating and then all
of a sudden your friends died and then
louis i used to open for louie louie you
know you're friends with blue yeah one
of the greatest nicest guys in the world
and um
i just became i started thinking about
death a lot and i was like and i
convinced myself i was dying
because i was coughing up blood and then
i could not leave my bed i for
weeks
i couldn't i canceled everything i
cancelled
18 weekends on the road
you know i mean i did i i said i'm
fucked and let me ask you like what was
it because i remember you know
being around you when like smoking weed
and stuff and it was like oh like this
is someone that has worked so hard in
program this is someone who like a lot
of the emotional wounds you've worked
really hard to heal you're in this
incredible relationship you have
you and i both i think bond strongly
over
making this business hollywood tv movies
whatever it is our higher power and this
one too many a million not enough even
if we do get a tv show it's like well i
it's it's not good and now i'm
embarrassed like we live in this
constant state of shame and
embarrassment and we allow we we cut
ourselves
with this business we allow it we have
the stockholm syndrome with it so we're
in this kind of like
like
uh
loop with no matter how much success we
get we still it's either not enough or
not the right kind or we feel like we're
accidentally shaming our peers by being
successful if we are successful we're
apologetic and embarrassed about it and
if we're not we're fucking miserable and
feel rejected
so i used to do bad auditions and i
would go to my car i would take a bottle
of water and smash my head over the head
until i was smash your head over the
head no i had splashed up all over my
head until i was bleeding
i would punish myself physically
for mistakes
or when i would you know and that's
because
when i was a kid i mean i know this is a
comedy podcast and people are listening
like oh here we go this is no don't
worry
there we go with the dark stuff but um
so you know you know when i was born you
know i just was unsafe you know my dad
used to beat everyone with golf clubs
and chasing every rum knocking my mom's
teeth out i mean this is what i
witnessed right you got free dental care
got it
right
i'm sorry bobby why did you laugh
i'm sorry i know but it was funny
i liked it but i know what it's like i
feel like fucking which bitch i feel
uniquely like when when you're sharing
something really emotional as a comedian
it's like it's it's hard so tell me if i
should stop no no because online also
people go
i don't want you to feel like you're
like i want whitney's podcast so i have
to be emotional
i'm gonna because i don't give a fuck
okay i don't give a fuck right i wish
you'd act like that before you go on
stage that's not that's the body that i
just i no longer give a fuck because i'm
gonna tell you what happened you should
give up you should give more of a fuck
about your hair because that's a bummer
what you're doing right now that you can
improve okay okay
so so i remember this happening and then
did you feel like it was as soon as you
heard the news about saggit then it was
like
without the bloody bloody you know i
mean mucus you know i mean i i think i
would have been able to just ride it a
little longer but because you had proof
you were like i also couldn't breathe
like i couldn't breathe every time you
even people would listen to me on
podcast like there's something wrong
with his breathing
like he's breathing and coughing it's
weird you know so it's like
and it got to the point where i couldn't
breathe at all like
you know i'm fucking dying so anyway i
have by the way i have 35 days no
cigarettes
no weed no alcohol no porn
nothing
okay
broke your street
so anyway um
so i i
i one kalala wasn't laying next to me
and it was like four in the morning and
i looked at her and i go
i need help
i need i'm gonna die
and i went to a a rehab uh mill
you know what a rehab mill is a puppy
it's like a poppy mail button for rehab
so now all these you can google it all
these rehabs are being bought by
corporations yeah right i like purdue
the guys that put on oxycontin were like
we really should get in the rehab
business yeah yeah so they bought you
know i mean so it's like instead of like
we're gonna treat these people we're
gonna get as many people in and as many
people out yeah and i went to one of
those i i showed up they're like just go
in that room i laid next and how did you
what was your do you mind if i just get
granular about like what did you do
obviously you are financially solvent
like but like what did you just go
ask your therapist for a suggestion
because sometimes when people that go to
rehab run their own
thing it's like you're not
well i did i mean like a gross guy i'm a
gross guy because i'm like i'm just
gonna go to the four seasons for a
couple days
no i actually asked where the
celebrities go yeah i'm gonna go
and they go this place
and they they named me this guy you know
years ago this person this person but
what i didn't realize and what no one
realized is that place was bought out by
a corporation so they got rid of like
high end
and just say let's just get everyone in
right so no one goes there anymore right
yeah so i was laying next to a naked 60
year old man going through
alcohol withdrawal and our beds were
like literally what was this
i can't tell you what okay okay okay i
don't wanna but like it wasn't in
california it was an in-house place and
this guy was literally going
screaming at the top was like
just screaming at the top of his lungs
and i'm just going what the fuck and
then i see a kid being dragged by his
hair
he's like i'm gonna fucking guide your
eyes with fucking ice picks and like
people just wandering around in hospital
garbs not knowing to go and i have to be
here for fucking 30 days
so i i i got out you left yeah and so i
went to another place which is it just
really quick is it's in and i'm not
trying to ask
where it was but you know in
my experience with this kind of stuff
it's like if you're like i'm going to
choose a place that's close to home
you'll probably will be able to leave if
you need to you know so sometimes i was
advised the first time i did i was
involved in an intervention with
somebody who needed to go to rehab they
basically were like the first one's
gonna be a wash don't don't spend money
on the first one because they're gonna
leave
they're gonna go fuck this shit yeah
detoxing is a nightmare yeah that's
interesting so just don't spit because
then you're just going to get resentful
and you're and you're going to waste all
this money and the health insurance
stuff by going to a rehab that because
we have so prohibitively expensive oh my
god you know so the first one usually
not that that's your first whatever but
just like the first one's probably not
going to take anyway because they're
just going to go i'm going to get the
fuck out of here and they can't make you
stay unless you've been 51 50 during a
conservatorship that's interesting yeah
this one's in the middle of a desert
though it's hard to leave sure so you
were burning differently i was just
burning man what you're describing
it was coachella same general live yeah
um so you were just like fuck this not
doing this well they wouldn't let me
leave and i had to call my lawyer sure
they wouldn't let me leave but so try to
stay there for four days and they had to
they so you sh you know i was on weed
and alcohol right because you were
detoxing which is sometimes a separate
from but three times a day you'd have to
wait in this line
and he would give you
a bowl just filled with pills mm-hmm and
i go what the fuck they're like just
take it you take like 15 pills i don't
know what the fuck is in it you didn't
know what they were no yeah now i know
it's adivan valley all these fucking
things right
gabba panted all these things yeah right
it's a while when you get more drugs in
rehab than you were on before i'm like
now
walking around this place for four days
with a bunch of teenagers
just smoking cigarettes in a soccer
field in the middle like it's fucking
breakfast my my question is what are the
teenagers saying about you like i love
it when i'm like i was this place of all
these weirdos and they have the same
story they're like and there was this
fucking guy with long hair smoking
cigarettes
trying to leave no no no they were not
they were like no those papaya they were
like tiger belly people
they were like your fans you went to
rehab no people just all your fans no no
not all of them but like there's like my
30 teenage kids maybe three or four of
them would go yummy i love kalila what's
going on you know this you know i mean
so it's just you know it is so funny
that you went to rehab and it was tiger
belly fans yeah there's a couple i'm
sure there was a couple whitney fans as
well all right
you have fans there too that is
so funny so anyway like why is this a
surprise i know there are fucking two or
three people that fucking react that
know the fuck i am sorry
it's like when i went to crazy girls on
sunset when i first started being on tv
and i was like and everyone's like
what's it like being like famous i was
like i don't really feel that famous i
can go to the airport i go to the
grocery store like i didn't like and and
me and zoe lister jones went to crazy
girls which is not even a strip club
it's like a bikini bar it's like the
girls that don't make it to the fully
nude ones like they don't book the
audition like so they go to this bikini
bar yeah and like half of them are
pregnant like they've got tampon strings
hanging out and they place the best like
90s hip-hop music and zoey and i went in
there every girl that worked there as
like a bikini bar stripper girl they
were like
yeah like oh this is where i'm famous
yeah you're on a network tv show and
you're also walking in with a fucking
co-star i know but it was like it was
like strippers what a surprise
they have televisions too
oh i don't know what i'll gouge your
eyes out
so anyway
you're a witch bitch anyway um so i left
the place
and the new place wasn't open for seven
days like an opening so i didn't know
rehab yeah so i had to go to l.a is this
a franchise no no the rehab wasn't open
yet maybe no no there's because the what
place i wanted to go is only eight they
only allow eight people at a time okay
right so it's like you know really
specialized sure you know i mean it's
the best
i had been there before i went there two
years ago
and so it's an elevator
[Applause]
you're so good you're so quick
and you're so great
and that's what i have to remind myself
you know it's whitney is who she is you
accept her be mindful about what she's
saying be very present
and just have empathy i just there's a
lot of holes in this story
so you leave the first one and you're
like i'm fuck this you're uncomfortable
you're restless irritable discontent i
want to go straight from here are you
allowed to call people no at that place
they take your phone so every time you
call you call payphone
you know so it's like it was really
difficult to get out getting hold of
people
this and that anyway i got out i had to
spend seven days in la and i just never
left the house just laid in bed and i
went to this new place and it so
it's outpatient and i was at the hotel
and i wait the wyatt hotel if it's
outpatient oh it's a different state
it's a different no it's the same state
different city
arizona that's where all the rehabs are
yeah isn't that interesting it's
interesting and i went to um the hotel
room and that night
i slept by the door of the hotel room
because i literally thought
if i because of bob died in a hotel room
so i literally thought i want them to
discover my body you know
or if i'm having a stroke or or i'm
dying
don't make a joke don't fucking pick a
chicken i'm sorry
i'm sorry it's just that you and bob are
the two people like i love the most and
thinking about either of you dead i i is
so that i don't cry
you deflect so i i was going to open the
door if i was getting a heart attack so
that they could find my body i mean
that's how
fucking crazy i was and then when i went
to the new place i didn't sleep for six
nights in a row
over 96 hours almost i no like 100 hours
of not sleeping you know and not i'm not
even talking laying in bed like my heart
racing pacing in my hotel room and are
you in those seven days did you come
back and and
like use to stay no i've been sober
since the first place oh wow okay so
i was like a couple weeks over at this
new place and bob's dead and bob's dead
and they
they asked me to leave because they
couldn't do any work because
what i need is emdr trauma work yep you
know i mean so um it's a game changer so
they told me to go um home
get blood work because if you think
you're dying
so like we get some blood work you're
like what
is that really fun
so um they go and i got blood work i
came at x-rays
um
blood pressure heart
everything and everything's fine okay
and
my doctor was like you're smoking weed
you know 24 hours a day and you're
smoking cigarettes 24 hours a day and
the amount you're smoking yeah you're
gonna cough up a lot yeah
so um
so now i'm back and i got a psychiatrist
and um i am on a little ritalin today
for second day and um i'm going to go
back to this place of
in a month and where we were looping
just the idea of like being was this the
first time you felt like a psychiatrist
brought up the idea of ocd and
uh no two years ago when i went to this
place it's a trauma place it's they have
the best therapists in the world and
it's the greatest place i've ever been
to and i've been to five in my life
and they um it's called betterhelp.com
do you have better
yeah you can go just to arizona and just
get better help from hotel in arizona if
you wanted to be outpatient yeah but
they um they match you with your um
therapist 48 hours or less you will get
a response
you can switch at any time anytime at
any time they're constantly adding new
therapists
it's not
it's you know what it's not it's not a
crisis
it's not self-help yeah
anyway go for 30 more seconds and then
we're going to yeah we got that in the
bag yeah that's funny
anyway so um
so now i have 30
oh let's see seven i don't know what's
the third what wait wait
one two three four
36 days
of everything now here's the thing
porn porn poor
look at you
i
didn't want to have sex with kalala
anymore
and she's wildly out of your league
just let me okay sorry absorb that my my
bad keep going god it hurt
of course
dude god made me god made me to go out
without a with a 342 girl named ting
tingting
that's what god made god made me was
like he's gonna be with tinkerine
but but hold on but colla here's so
here's what i'll say i'm not gonna say
i'm just
as
someone that
did
read a bunch of neurology books to try
to figure out
how life works
you two have been together for how long
almost 10 years 10 years i mean like i'm
not saying you shouldn't be off porn and
that like it is one too many million not
enough and porn can be very damaging and
toxic but is is all of that just your
fault
is like being with someone have you ever
been with someone for 10 years before
it's a long time no i always had a
two-year mark
because this is going to
i loved all my girlfriends
but um
i was which is why i had to kill them
the way you say that is so i love all
that which is why they had to die if i
can't have you no one can but i've
always
at the two-year mark exactly two years
i just go i'm done which is by the way
there is a little bit of like science
like biological basis for that which
which is like yeah because it's like you
know we're we're wired essentially to be
making have you ever read cupid's
poisoned arrow no one really i'm going
to go i have it downstairs it's about
how basically like you know in love and
sex addiction porn addiction we're not
designed to just have orgasms all the
time you're kind of only designed to
have an orgasm when you're procreating
because that's how it was in tribal
times you didn't just get to
uh so so in you know a navajo indian
didn't go back behind a tree and jerk
off you know what i
i i
i i'm not you know what here's what i'm
saying they jerked off
all the time back then okay i don't
think moses jerked off but
how dare you he did with what myrrh no
did you get two slabs
with
[Laughter]
but um it is amazing how much we say oh
god during sex yeah yeah um but no just
what the idea was that it was a reward
for procreating you know we now have sex
for sport almost exclusively most of the
time when we have sex the goal is to not
get the person pregnant it's just the
idea of what it does to your brain when
you have an orgasm for the most part
your primary brain thinks you've just
procreated yeah so the idea of i'm
having sex with you to not have a kid
we've been together two years our
primordial reptile brain thinks that two
years ago when we had sex for the first
time that a baby was made nine months
later and that you need to stay in love
with me and stick around to protect the
child and your offspring for another
year or so and then by the time the
baby's one or two i don't really need
you anymore and then you don't make
dopamine for me anymore and then you
move on and procreate with someone else
so two years is about the amount of time
wait wait they did that back in the day
no that's how our primordial brain views
it so we are our bread the two-year mark
is about when i don't need your
protection for my the offspring you made
with me anymore so when did that when
did that change there's a movie called
the female brain and i encourage you all
to watch it i don't want to watch it
it's a nightmare but there's a whole
storyline about this example it's really
bad yeah you know what
you heard correctly
it is one compromise after another it
was a nightmare ruined my life and took
away my ability to have biological
children but there is a storyline that
is exactly about this it's the sofia
vargara and dion cole storyline which is
about like after you know after after
you
have an orgasm with somebody if you and
i are together we have sex two years
later is about when your reptilian brain
stops making oxytocin for me because
it's your your primary brain's internal
clock of going i've procreated with this
person we've raised the kid it can walk
now it's they don't need me anymore i'm
not gonna move on and procreate with
someone else because my my
males or females as well females is a
little bit of this it depends on if
they're on birth control or not
that's a whole other thing and olfactory
glands and it's a very boring thing yeah
yeah but but so i would say don't i just
am the person that's always saying to
people like don't be mad at yourself for
not being wanting to like fuck like
bunnies after two years because we're
the cupid's poison arrow lays the
science out of that really helpfully
yeah but you know that's fine and i
believe you but um so 10 years but women
also want intimacy right they want to be
held they want to be told i love you
they want to be some of them yeah but i
wasn't doing any of that with kaleidos
yeah it became you know you know because
of my porn addiction it became strictly
business sure and a friendship and
that's not what she's in it for so sure
she's doing it for
also i also want to say because i'm a
kid from trauma and ptsd sure you know i
cannot engage in suffering anymore other
people's suffering right so it's like
you know
you know i'm sure i know i know asa
akira who's just a a businesswoman
she's bright uh do we can we say porn
star still or is it or is it an adult
movie science worker okay adult movie
star
i'm an adult movie star yeah
howdario
she's like the number like she was the
number one you know one of the best and
um she's she has a kid now she's what
does it mean to be one of the best porn
stars one of the richest or one of the
most flexible like it's no like in
acting like you win oscar if you're
great right they have the avian awards
yes i know she's won many of those i
know i've hosted them before right so
she's got plaques and trophies and stuff
but anyway um what i'm saying is um when
you go to a strip club and you watch
porn you know you're just supporting
other people's trauma
you know what i mean and ptsd i'm not
saying all of them are like that but you
know if you watch european ones
obviously you know in especially eastern
european ones they're forced into yeah
just out of necessity yeah sure and you
know sometimes families give their
daughter but how do you know because
it's like in this time where we're going
we're supporting sex workers if you are
a teacher and you're getting paid
nothing and you want to breastfeed on
only fans for an extra 100 grand a month
we're supposed to be like that's totally
fine now as long as it's your choice and
it's consensual like when do you know i
usually am like that bruise is a little
too big for me to enjoy this porn how do
you know if they're it's what it's
whoever it's your individual
decision right it's like i don't eat
mcdonald's right because i think it's
but my niece eats mcdonald's i think
mcdonald's is poison
sure and if you keep eating it you're
gonna die but people eat it and i have
nothing i don't think they should but
they fucking do it anyway and i'll give
a fuck but but to be if i may um
that's are you saying that that's
capitalizing on the trauma of animals
because it's meat because the the porn
thing is if if because there's here's
the thing there is a huge rise in
amateur porn where people that are
dating can centrally film themselves
having sex and put it on yeah i get what
you're saying it's not my place to say
i'm participating in a rape or a trauma
because i don't know
i'm not telling anyone to stop working
in their field spending points or
watching or watching it i'm just saying
for me yeah yeah it feels right that's
what it feels like it feels weird it
feels like i'm supporting something
that's
evil yeah
and um that's just me i'm working on a
uh
a bit about like how um because i'm
dating a guy that seems like nine years
younger than me and everyone's like well
why would you want to be with someone
that was like exclusively raised by porn
and i i guess i'm just like no one talks
about and you're talking about now the
negative effects of porn on men
and uh like he has all these fears uh
that i've never seen in a man like he
won't let me alone with the pizza guy
like he gets really nervous that's
really funny he won't let me hang out
with my step brother yeah like he's
really stressed graceful he won't let me
do the laundry he thinks i'm going to
like get stuck in the laundry machine
that's 80s porn he's got
that's when they used to do storylines
they don't do that anymore they do gonzo
it's fine
yes he doesn't like it when i'm like on
the yoga ball at the gym he's like get
off that yoga ball don't you want me
working out just like the new paranoias
that guys have but yeah i mean good on
you for like knowing that it was not uh
because i think it seems like it's just
taken me my entire life to to make peace
with porn going okay if the guy i'm with
is watching porn and jerking off it's
not personal he's not trying to hurt me
it's like taking a piss it's just like
you know taking a shit or something but
when you know that it's making your life
unmanageable and you were able to tell
on yourself that's
yeah i mean well i felt like my
relationship was falling apart and um
she's a great girl and i just you know
i want it to work and and did you feel
like because what i hear is when you get
desensitized when you watch enough porn
that by the time you're with
a person irl it's just becomes a
transaction it's like transactional it's
no also there's no it's impersonal
there's a detachment to it and it's fast
like i
you know would do it like
you know sex is a to do it's an event
sometimes
okay right there's you know foreplay
there's you know i mean you have to
consent
i mean yeah it's got to be consensual i
don't consent to foreplay
quick as possible yeah so for me it's
like you know i'd rather just go in my
bathtub watch porn real quick your
bathtub
yeah because i don't want her to watch
me doing it so i go i'm taking a bath
she knows what i'm doing the number one
that's how i know someone's jerking off
because that's not true you take baths
i'd never take showers and i've been
like that's a kid i'm like that too
actually that's really weird that's
really weird yeah yeah if i'm in a rush
i'll take a shower okay but if i'm i
have some time back baby all day long
yeah yeah so
yeah i don't even clog up the bathtub at
first i'll just sit in front
the faucet part and just splash
okay it's great okay so don't judge me
one time i walked in a friend of mine in
the bath and she was like taking forever
this was like in college and i walked in
and she was there was no water in the
tub she her like undercarriage was up
against the
the
faucet and it was just like that's how
she masturbated it was the water just
going on her genitals in the bath i did
that my parents bathtub faucet in their
bathtub in their bedroom yeah
was so scary it was so strong right that
during the days i would just go put my
penis on the faucet right and just kind
of hold my penis but but the sensation
of the water rushing it made it feel so
good
and one day i was doing it like this and
i hear
and i turn around my dad
had to come back home to pick something
up and he saw me and we never talked
about it bummer it was a bummer dude
this is the emdr this is why this is one
like the emperor from star wars
was fucking traumatic that is i am so gr
like
every day that i like miss my dad who's
passed away or feel bad about our
relationship or have regrets i'm just
grateful he never saw me naked
that's the only thing i'm like totally
fine i'm like he died before he ever
accidentally saw me naked and that's all
i could ever ask for but if you wait
your toothpick covered in saliva at me
one more time
you know what we never here's the thing
i'm not going to let you blue ball
though zip x what is that is that your
yeah this is a because i quit smoking
this is a nicotine um toothpick can i
have yeah two milligrams of the best oh
see i love to i love tea tree oil
toothpicks and you know it reminds me of
do you remember the movie uncle buck
yeah the guy with the guy at the bowling
alley put the the the toothpick in his
mouth
yeah yeah i just i think about that as
like a performer now and i'm like did
they improvise that like did that actor
improvise that moment like looking back
don't you think he probably did yeah
yeah so here's something as you're as
you're drawing
i'm gonna so i'm gonna you talk
and i'm gonna write something down i'm
very shy
but i do i do think it's important that
we address the the diagnosis of the add
ocd thing because as someone that shies
away from discussing that because i feel
like in 10 years we're going to look
back at this and it's just not going to
hold up or that people get very
sensitive about like this is what actual
add is an ocd and whatever i've been
diagnosed with both i know there's a
spectrum but i do feel very um
a little bit resentful that it took till
i was like 37 years old for someone to
diagnose my add
uh uh because i i think that i don't
present to someone that has a dd i've
been able to achieve things i've been
able to finish scripts i've been able to
work really hard but it also manifests
in little things like
repeating yourself when you're talking
like i struggled for the longest time
like
and i think a part of it has to do with
not being like heard as a child i would
repeat myself talk really loudly
interrupt people
yeah you said that you said that earlier
that you finished people's sentences you
said that early downstairs right uh i
i i if you're bombing i'll try to help
you that's a different thing
than
i had like a tick it was almost like a
manic tip
where i i was so afraid someone was
going to get bored or abandon me that i
would just like interrupt when they were
talking yeah but you don't have like i
have to like at a movie theater
if i turn around one time yes i have to
turn around two more times sure so this
is what you'll see
okay
when you're looking back at this no this
is a smoothie right here right
[Laughter]
yeah there could be gunshots in the back
like real guns i won't turn around
you're just trying to show off your
thick main appearance
so yeah so so i when i was a kid if i
would like stub my toe on a table i'd
have to stub my other toe on purpose
it's like even it out so do you do that
now or no
so you have a little bit of that i have
a lot of things have to be even like if
i like i i have this little tick where
i'll use my right thumbnail to sort of
make a callus on my right pointer finger
and i have to do it with my left one too
so that they're even like if i did if i
if i scratch this finger ten times i
then have to do the left one ten times
you know it's the same thing yeah yeah
it's the same it's like little things
like that where things just it's it's
about control and i think as a child
there's so little you can control that
when you're able to like organize your
books by color or whatever you just have
this false sense of control in your
little world so i think as i've gotten
older al anon helped me with that in
inner child work yeah and that's also
what i love as you can tell by this
podcast i need everything to be very
neat and tidy
i'm gonna leave all these toothpicks on
the table but my point is is that um
that's what i love about you because
there's a couple of guys you and mark
that i can go to and talk about
you know um
these things you know
12-step stuff you know the language you
know and it's there's a safety in that
but i want to show you this um
what okay this is
circles of intimacy let's just call it
there so he's holding up an index card
with two circles it kind of looks like
an egg and then he
he misjudged how big the card was so the
the circle is
like goes off the card right
so in the center circle imagine the
center circle right that's supposed to
be me and god
right and by god you mean whatever your
perception of god or spirituality or
it's within right it's like the
spiritual connection within right and
what i would say about god just really
quick for people to hear god and they go
ugh because they were like catholic and
molested or something yeah because that
could be a triggering word for people
what we say in program is like you don't
have to believe in god you just have to
believe that you're not god yeah and if
you believe that you're not your god can
be anything right the universe
eva duvernay scientology yeah yeah you
know pete davidson's dick whatever you
want
mine is pete
so um you know the center circle should
be you and your spirituality the second
circle should be um your loved ones you
know like your girlfriend money
got it loved ones yeah yeah does that is
that chosen loved ones or does that
family count
that's the thing
in that second circle this is what i was
taught right is um should be not a lot
of people it's you know you can't be
that intimate with everyone right so
it's like it's my right now my second
circle is kalyla we forget about okay so
in in i did this um attachment strategy
course that was similar and you had
tears of friends you had a's b's and c's
because what we try to do is like people
like us do you just wink at me
yeah
i don't know how to wave
i've never i don't know how to wave no
one ever told me i'm so bad waving you
know how my boyfriend waves at people
yeah yeah that's not see yeah do this
just wait you just winked but this
wasn't the time or the place for that i
don't care you weren't
i'm tired of people telling me what and
why what i cannot tell you i was
literally just curious because you
earlier were talking about in this
climate yeah and you want to see my
pussy but
no not worried about winking at me like
that i'm just curious to see what that
monster looks like
is that eileen warnos anyway
so anyway but but really quick there's i
think that people like us
not us i won't speak for i'll speak for
myself i think that we
get uh uh accused of having intimacy
issues or we can confuse about intimacy
because number one we um conflate
intimacy with proximity of being you
have to be with someone physically or
around someone a lot in order to be
intimate with them and number two we can
trauma bond with strangers very
intensely once a month yeah and it's a
false sense of intimacy whereas intimacy
the idea is having some kind of
consistency and accountability and not
just we're going to share about how we
were molested for an hour 2 a.m that
okay so
once a month okay this is what i would
so but my whole life especially in my
20s yeah the number one thing was always
show business
it was stand up i i cared more about
that than anything else on planet earth
the biz of show is to make it yeah right
which i but but i think if i may because
i just as we talk i'm sorry because i'm
big on with you don't talk about my
friend like that yeah like it's like
we equate success in show business
with
physical safety financial freedom
security and love so
i i just think that it sounds a little
bit like we're dickheads and we're like
i just want to make it in show business
it's not like i just want to be famous
like it's no it's not about that it's
also like
our scarcity complex and like
wanting to
be solvent financially
yeah but also when you st you know as
especially if for you know i started
comedy in 95
and there were no asians doing no no in
san diego they were not really genuine
yeah duty to negotiation
bjork and judy
so um you know i also was so difficult
to get in and when i realized
it's difficult now but when you first
start doing stuff you don't know anybody
you're just signing up at an open mic
you get a you know one o'clock am one am
you know called
state of the time
before the internet
getting
booked as a comedian
looking back i cannot believe we start
like physically are alive yeah we would
show up to comedy clubs wait for hours
with a bunch of legitimately
narcissistic unhoused people yeah i
don't think you can say homeless anymore
unhoused people like
mentally ill people yeah i used to hang
out with a guy who wore a doll house on
his head and he would give me a ride and
he would drive me to the club with a
dollhouse a little dollhouse on his head
and i'd have to help him disassemble it
to take it off yeah
and then various drug addicts that did
what you said earlier uh referred to as
real meth yeah
yeah i had a guy pull out my car
at the comedy store parking lot tracks
name is ari shafir
yeah like it was just it's like and then
even when you know and look i have
nothing but like
like glowing things to say about all the
people that hazed me and growing up in
that but then even when you do get in
you're still getting like
abused on purpose instead of just i mean
i would sit outside for seven hours on
sunset boulevard alone as a 23 year old
woman like waiting to do three minutes
yeah with a bunch of weird i mean it's
wild but the problem when you put show
business number one when you don't get
the audition when there's a couple of
years when you're not really working or
hot and you know i had that those years
right
you just spend all that time completely
depressed no self-worth and if i may
yeah the couple people that would be the
friends you would attune to that would
understand what you're going through are
your competition
right so yeah yeah so for me coming up
as a girl it was like the the at that
time when no one that was not no one
wanted women doing comedy uh the three
or four other girls that were doing it
with me
the three people that i feel like could
be comforting or medicinal to know and
hang out with
we were pitted against each other yeah
so it was like even more lonely yeah and
so um
but what i've had to do is um
it's also like you know i've had fears
of being canceled you know i mean
because of the things that i've said
and and then that would be traumatic
right for me and i would obsess about it
yeah but what what i've done in the last
month is i've literally i think i feel
like i've changed
how i view what i'm doing now
and i don't care as much i care more
about living and i have other dreams
like i want to open an animal sanctuary
like i want to buy a ranch and i want to
get pigs and cows and raise them you
know on land and stuff and i have other
dreams
and so when you rearrange your circles
of intimacy right
it i'm sorry can i just say really quick
when people get sober isn't it ironic
that they sound the most on drugs
what do you mean just like what's like
look i want to get pigs and cows and
like that is the most high thing anyone
could say
which is i just love that whenever i
hang out with my friends that are
recently sober the shit they say is way
more high yeah you know whereas when
you're high you're like i want to start
a business
you know i want to raise land animals on
land yeah
i want pigs and cows like i'm like it's
just a it's a funny thing that happens
that
well i'll tell you why though
you fucking witch bitch
this is your new thing
you're the only one i'm going to call
you that's your new name huncle okay do
you like it you're just
branding for me i've been out of i need
a teacher of ideas it's going to be a
hot uh shirt but my point is is that so
um
you know you love dogs right mm-hmm some
of them no you
no
you know that's true you're like you're
like us in the sense we foster yes right
we
i know that kalila when she has any
questions about fostering or dogs she
calls you right so i feel like we have
that in common and we know that dogs
have an emotional connection right
they're sentient beings they recognize
they become
family and there's nothing more healing
i think than the unconditional love of
an animal that doesn't care what you do
for a living doesn't care what show
you're on doesn't care how much money
you have
you know so that that is for me a lot of
my like recovery in in trying to scrape
together a modicum of self-worth has
just been like i respect and love this
dog i trust its instincts it's evolved
over millions of years to be able to
tell who's safe and who's cool and who's
not and if this dog likes me i must not
be a complete piece of shit right so
when you have you ever seen photos of
the yulin dog eating festival in china
the fact that you're bringing this up
let me just finish what i have a point i
have a fucking point which way no nobody
just fucking listen to what i'm fucking
saying all right i know i'm not riddled
right now but you got me all crazy okay
but what i'm gonna say is when people
that are close friends of mine are like
hey do you know about the yulin dog
festival i'm like hey bitch unmute me
you know that's like my major cause and
i post about it all the time okay so it
breaks your fucking heart right you get
rage
and anger yeah right why
because you know that they're emotional
sentient beings you're right that
connect but cows and pigs do the same
thing
when you raise a cow from a calf right
right right they let's say they're out
in your pasture and you have a house
some of them will wait by your door in
the morning of course right and when you
walk out they'll greet you right they'll
sneak up behind you and lick your face
right and they don't do that with
anybody else because you have an
emotional connection with that thing
they have feelings right because they
don't watch porn yeah
i love cal poly porn is my favorite by
the way
so um
and pigs do the same thing right there's
so many animals do the same thing
so um i've been
maybe you know what you just maybe i'm
newly sober i think you're right
what's up maybe i'm on a pink cloud stop
all right let me just say right i think
cloud is what they say when you get
sober and you're like suddenly
everything's clear and you feel really
good right and then go it goes away so
um it doesn't have to be maybe i'm on a
pink cloud maybe i'm i think you're
seeing clearly i think that you're
seeing like i am but i feel like i'm not
as well no you're not you're not it's
it's more like it's more like
to say all this to me it's just like
this is my
shit like my main drug is animals at
this point like you know so i totally
i'm with you no one is more with you but
but the one thing about the animal thing
is
when we
adopt animals get farms have all the
pigs and cows we are setting ourselves
up for future heartbreak and that's the
place i am right now in my life is going
like
i have all these dogs and animals in my
life that i love so much that are gonna
die soon and that is gonna fucking i've
talked to my therapist about it i'm like
when frank right over here when if
something ever happens to frank he's
gonna live forever
um
i am like planning a heroin addict i was
like can i i'll just do heroin you can
be there for like a month yeah because i
i'm afraid of the the amount of like
most of my
fear in life revolves around what's
gonna happen when my heart gets broken
by my animals because it's kind of the
only thing that can hurt me anymore at
this point
because i've i've i was born with a
broken heart my heart's been broken so
many times by people that now it's like
the pain of losing an animal is unlike
anything else well you don't save their
hair saliva toenail that's what i do
save their saliva so i can clothe them
with what business clone no cloning is
real bad
no
the process of cloning is really
inhumane and you're getting i don't know
what do you mean the process the process
the way that they clone dogs is it's you
know uh ask your
relatives uh that's really that's where
they do it and they
basically take a dog who's like the
surrogate dog they put an egg in it and
they have like five or six pups they
have to do it by cesarean section the
surrogate mom does die
most of them are wonky duds lemons and
then you get one and it's still like a
little off it's like there's just so
many dogs that need to be rescued
there's so many dogs that need something
you don't need to and everybody who
clones their dog i'm like your dog
sucked before why are you making another
one of your little okay think about the
people who clone their dogs they were
already weird alien breeder dogs in the
first place yeah
i love my dogs more than humans
and you're right i
and one of my dogs is 12. yeah and i
keep looking i pet them every day and i
know you can give an nad the nad which
is the uh really good for humans the
anti-aging thing uh there's some
evidence that it works in dogs and oh i
thought it was nda like n.a.d you do you
have to sign the nda you
yeah it's hard but but i think it's but
but no what i'm hearing is this
incredible recovery because you're
you're like
thinking about animals and the things
that because happiness is an inside job
and you're thinking about the things
that make you happy and make you feel
whole
and without
substances
that's the whole deal yeah and i think a
lot of addiction recovery is about
replacing an addiction a negative
addiction with a positive addiction so
when someone's like i just got sober and
i'm doing crossfit six times a week
everyone goes like well that's just
another addiction fine as long as you're
not like driving drunk and killing
yourself like why not so for me a lot of
times it's rescuing animals i'm like i
know this is addictive it's making my
life unmanageable i'm missing like nine
limbs i'm covered in scars i under i
know but it's definitely better than
yeah they try to get me because i said
the last place i go i'm done with porn
and they and they go this is what they i
laughed so loud they go
what about the video games
i'm like fuck you
because fuck you because it's
whack-a-mole you know what i mean like
why you deal with one and another comes
up i mean the good news is that most
video games are basically porn at this
point but you shoot the hooker at the
end right you shoot the idea
you're hunting hookers yeah yeah um but
uh how did you come on the realization
that porn is making my life unmanageable
did you just decide one day
like
no no no
no no she would be i know my girlfriend
would be like a lot of guys talk about
that but why aren't we having sex and i
would make excuses like um i'm getting
old i'm 50. you know what i mean or you
know i mean i can cut that out
you know i have a lot of stress or
whatever it might be you know what i
mean but um
it's to
just to get in a healthier place in all
like i don't call people back
i don't text people back i i have an mo
just disappearing and this and that yeah
and i want to change but here's all of
that if you if someone texts you and
then you text them back
then it just starts the whole process
over again
i know i kind of i i think you and i are
like polar opposites in that as if
someone texts me i would like pull over
to respond to them right away
and i could use a little more like i'll
respond tomorrow when i have some time
yeah you'll go weeks and months never
yeah you just won't respond i won't
respond to people at all right and then
and what does that mean i don't know i
mean i ran into my friend david arnold
you know david of course but to be fair
most people
there's no nothing to say back i i do i
am fine he was like hey what's up and
you're like ah right so but david arnold
goes he go you know he was a little
distant and i go what's up cause i've
known him for 30
years writer he's like dude i've called
you
50 times in my life you've never called
me back yeah right and in my head i was
just like you know what man
you're fucking right i mean what a
terrible thing i apologize you know
and i'm not doing that i don't i don't
want to do that anymore but here's yes
and here's what i will say i do think
that we shouldn't be just responding to
everyone out of obligation either yeah
you know because that's all we would do
if we just responded to people so so but
when you don't respond to me or if i
don't text you back i'm going like well
i'm going to see him tonight anyway you
know what i mean right right i think you
have to look at your motives of why
you're responding to somebody and if
you're responding just out of obligation
you just got to go maybe i'm at capacity
i know that's not what you're doing
yours is like pathological and
self-sabotaging but i did find i've
spent i spent so much of my life just
responding to people because they texted
me or going out to lunch and hikes just
because someone asked me there is a
point as an adult where you have to go
like if i were to if i had responded
every text and every phone call that's
all i would do and we do have to protect
our time and energy and
not like force people to make us invest
in friendships we don't want to be in
yeah so there's a happy medium can i ask
you a quick question it's kind of a side
note okay because okay it's a behavioral
thing so um
last year when you don't respond to me
i'm like thank god
um
last year i was in hungary and i was at
you know how
doing what obviously nothing just doing
a tour the most interesting thing you
say you give no you just throw away yeah
i was just in rehab that was in rehab
i go all over the world that's where
that's that's where the um uh the
ovaries is anonymous yeah that's for the
overeaters we have sort of eating
disorder
so i wasn't hungry and i was in a store
and they you know i they don't know who
i am but
i wasn't having a conversation with
somebody because what do you do i go i'm
a community goes i love bert kreicher
that's what he said and i go
what
yeah and i go yeah he's a good friend of
mine he's like no you don't know him
right so i facetimed burke chrysler
right he picked up this whenever any
comedian facetimes another comedian you
run into some you're ambushing me with a
fan of mine right yeah so so that's
exactly what it is so but
but the question is this right and bert
answered i go hey there's a fan here
right and then i hung you know he was
super nice
i go thank you for picking up i hung out
and they treated me different right but
am i doing it for bert to reach out to a
fan or am i doing it to brag
she's someone you'll never see again
yeah so what am i doing it for
honestly to get the exchange over with
i think so you're just trying to get it
over with it that that honestly isn't
bragging it's a fucking bracket it's the
fastest way to get out of that situation
that you've you're you're in and in bro
yo is that how you pronounce it you're
in a a morass of this person where
someone's like do you know this person
now you have to prove to that no you
just you comedians are obsessed with
justice and someone just accused you of
being a liar
yeah and now you're like all right i'm
gonna fucking call this motherfucker so
i don't have to go through the rest of
my trip in hungary
thinking that this guy that works at
basically the hungarian version of
forever 21 is gonna call me a liar yeah
how dare you so it's really more that
like when people will be like so yeah
like accuse me of like i'll just like
here i'm gonna call a bitch because we
have to prove ourselves i think as
comedians we have to prove ourselves
every day all the time
and the idea that you have to prove to
your yourself to this fucking guy who
just accused you of lying to him but why
can't we just say
why can't i just do this i know him no
you don't okay and just move on because
we're obsessed with justice and because
someone called you a liar and we're
comedians are a lot of things but we're
not liars
okay that is my biggest third rail when
someone accuses me of like lying or
being dishonest like if someone uh uh i
have this thing where if i'm late for
something
i will take a picture of the traffic i'm
in and just send it because i'm like i
i never want anyone to think i'm lying
so i'm obsessed with providing proof at
all times oh i would totally fucking do
that yeah okay and then i would um
take gasoline and i would put it all
over the store
and then i would set it on fire yeah
okay let me ask you another question
then just real quick how dare you accuse
someone you don't know of lying like why
would you lie about knowing burke
crystal why what a dumb lie yeah but
also i he could also see you know i
could lie too and say if i was an open
mic yeah and he goes i love brook
chrysler i know him right he could i
could see an open mic or doing if they
don't know him
in hungary maybe
why are you talking to people at stores
in hungary like there's so many because
they don't a lot of them don't speak
english so when somebody does speak
english because you know i you know i
had like weeks off at a time yeah yeah
yeah you know i was shooting something
they were like you know you have two
weeks off there's also sometimes you
have to lie to get out of something so i
had someone come and help me hang stuff
up yeah like uh uh for this podcast
studio
and
sometimes people will come to shows and
they'll bring me like knickknacks and
trinkets and i this is where i put them
up and someone made like legos of me see
they're all falling down i don't know
how to keep them standing up so those
are legos of me with like pink hair and
blue hair and whatever yeah and so this
guy was hanging stuff up and he was
looking at the legos and he goes oh i
collect legos and i was like oh these
these are actually like little legos of
me and he was like you were in the lego
movie and i was like
you live yes
i just was like
by the time i explained that i'm not in
the lego movie and then people just make
legos of me like it's just like and
what's fucked up i was in a lego movie
and i don't have a fucking lego because
i'm saying i'm like the fact that he
jumped from you were in the leg i'm like
no i didn't buy the lego of my someone
and then i'm like i'm gonna sound like
i'm lying if i say no a fan just made me
a lego of myself and he's coming back on
thursday and i'm fully waiting for him
to be like i googled you and you're not
in the lego movie i was like yeah well
you just made things weird no i want you
to apologize so sometimes i'll lie just
to get out of it's like easier to just
say yes
we now take a break
from our guest to talk about another
kind of break slash gap
gaps in the diet
oh my god i'm never letting you bring us
into a sponsor copy again i'm so sorry
ritual cause you know why this is why i
go back to my thing when you try too
hard it sounds fake and corny i have
used ritual vitamins even before i had a
podcast okay there's a strong argument
to be made that taking ritual vitamins
gave me the fortitude and the tenacity
and the physical and emotional and
mental strength to be able to start a
podcast in the first place it is my fuel
okay over 97 of women age 19 to 50 are
not getting enough vitamin d from out of
their diet that's psychotic and 95
are not getting the recommended daily
intake of ketomega threes and that
explains everything that's wrong with
this world what ritual essential for
women 18 plus multivitamin was
formulated by exhaustive
research to help fill nutrient gaps in
the diet of women ages 18
plus
so not near whitney it is formula speak
for yourself it is because i'm saying
like we're 17. i'm
[Laughter]
it's formulated with nutrients to help
support that emily has decided this is
solely a video medium and she will ham
up to the camera almost exclusively to
communicate look it's formulated with
nutrients to help support brain health
bone health blood health and provide
antioxidant support ritual doesn't stop
there they invested in gold standard
university-led clinical trials to prove
the impact of essential for women 18
plus multivitamin and the results
question mark essential for women 18
plus was shown to increase vitamin d
levels by 43 and omega 3 dha levels by
41
in 12 weeks so you don't have to sun
your butthole for your vitamin d anymore
you don't have to do the perineum
sunning oh man oh man
right now rituals offering our listeners
10 off your first three months visit
virtual.com whitney and turn healthy
habits into a ritual that's ten percent
off at ritual.com which nay i'm starting
to think
that our sponsors
are catching on to the fact that we hate
water and i'm sorry to think water isn't
all it's cracked up to be
i cannot drink water on its own
it makes me sick it makes me gag and
it's pointless i only like water when
it's carbonated with a lot of sugar in a
coke bottle
and we have just discovered liquid iv
okay
in 16 ounces of water hydrates faster
and more efficiently than water alone
liquid iv contains five essential
vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c with
three x's the electrolytes of
traditional sports drinks liquid iv is
made with premium ingredients non-gmo
and free from gluten dairy and soy
obviously
what makes liquid iv so effective emily
do you know yes it's the science of
cellular transport technology ctt that's
trademarked it's designed to enhance
rapid absorption of water and other key
ingredients into the bloodstream if
you're not waiting around for your water
to so it's time it was time to wait
around for your water to absorb it takes
forever one stick of liquid iv in 16
ounces of water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone
grab liquid iv in bulk nationwide at
costco or you can get 25 off when you go
to liquidity.com and use code whitney at
checkout and you can put these in your
purse and they don't explode everywhere
that's great and then everyone doesn't
think you're on cocaine yep and that's
25 off anything you order when you use
promo code whitney liquidive.com
experience better hydration today at
liquidity.com comma promo code whitney
they have great flavors mine is favorite
is
i just use the lemon lime oh i love pina
colada oh i feel like i'm on vacation
[Laughter]
emily
has lost her mind and i am so into it
i think you're over i think this is your
first time ever emily's finally hydrated
this is your personality
back to our guest
one time so i did oddball once and
oddball is a stand-up no one you they
know what it is i love that you do your
that like you go on podcast as if you're
just talking to the live nation
christmas all right so odd bell was a
tour and it's like you know they have
like 10 huge comics and it was like for
like 25 000 seats we were doing these
like outdoor arenas right but i did it
the last year so anyway
you know when you book a flight you you
they don't book your flight you book
your flight right so my manager always
books me coach
yeah because it's he she's like sweet is
texas
right yeah yeah but i show up at the
airport there everyone's there
right and they all have first class
right
so they seat first right and it's all my
friends like sakura sebastian manoska
dane cook everyone right and um
i walk by and they booed me when i
walked by
so i took a nap on the couch i woke up
and i had first class pillows
piled up
on me like 12 of them like i could have
died
but it's so funny that they would
just go back and just put pillows on my
body and they were laughing so you've
done the warm cookies oh yeah yeah
what's a warm cookie the warm cookie
first classic at the end they give you a
warm cookie where you're just like what
yeah yeah yeah i love the warm cookies
that is so funny
so funny
and then but this is how i love tom
seguro so i didn't know him he was the
only one i didn't know that well and he
put most of the pillows on my back you
know him well now he's
so when i got off the flight
we were my manager was supposed to get
me a ride to the airport to the hotel
and she never did that so i have to take
a cab now sure so i go to luggage
and he didn't leave
and he goes hey you don't have a ride do
you and i go
no i have to get a cab he's like no
we're going to the same hotel right i go
yeah he goes get in my limo and
and i was friends with sebastian
friends with dane friends with all these
guys and they obviously they're
build higher and they got shit to do i
guess i don't know but
he i didn't know him at all i'd never
talked to him in my life i knew who he
was by name only and as soon as i went
in that limo i just looked at him i went
yeah this guy is a war buddy he's the
best he's the best sebastian have you
ever flown on a plane with sebastian
no not not in that iteration many times
yeah so we i've tried
around the world one of the nicest guys
ever sebastian yeah i mean
i've been going through some hard times
and
i talked to him and he
you know got emotional he's like you can
call me 24 hours a day you know that
right and you know his schedule and he
says that because he knows you won't
i'm always like bobby i'm always here at
any time knowing that for the 15 years
you wouldn't respond to a text yeah yeah
but i'm just saying that he's just um i
think comedians right now i think it's
like
the pandemic was a big mental health
challenge i think for a lot of us yeah
people that already were having mental
health challenges if you wink at me one
more time
um like i think that it i think that
that it either tore us apart or brought
us together you know and i think that um
comedians when the ability to
tell you know
make drunk strangers laugh at night when
that was taken away i also think that
this is a this is a hot take so
comedians i do feel like a lot of what
was keeping comedians
and like anyone i'm sure this is the
case in any field but this is just what
i happen to know like what kept us sane
was a lot of us in the hallway talking
attuning to each other
being able to have
conversations that we now monetize for
podcasts and we kind of stopped having
the off
microphone we stopped having like
any comedian when i'm in the hallway we
start talking about how's your life
going with the problems i'm struggling
with this like you know let's just
podcast on third let's just save it for
the podcast
we started monetizing our therapeutic
medicinal
attuning and now we don't we only do it
for public consumption yeah and i think
that's unhealthy
i agree yeah because what i learned is i
use
my shame
my um my regret just all that stuff and
i expose all of it like
i was molested my dad used to beat me
and just be specific but it's my way of
pushing people away
because you have to hold some things to
yourself and process them yourself right
but all my career i've been like look at
my dick look at my body i'm ugly you
know and just all this shit like i was
you know
constant constant and it's just a
defense mechanism and this is i didn't
make this up but um who was it that said
i say it all the time uh and i don't
know who i'm plagiarizing but that uh
comedians do stand up to control how
we're embarrassed
because we're i know who said that i
don't know who said it i don't know oh
that's great and i bring it up all the
time and it's something that made me
that's what i do i go up and i'm like
i'm this i'm ugly my last name is coming
so i'm gonna be single forever i'm like
i'm gonna say all the shit about myself
before you get to say it that's exactly
what it is it's exactly what it is yeah
but it's not healthy you can't hurt me
you can't fire me because i quit yeah
because the first year i did opening
anthony this is 20 years ago
i left i left
i left halfway during the um interview
because they were fucking ripping me
apart
and when you're a young comic and you're
like oh jim norton i was with jim norton
greg geraldo patrice o'neill they're all
in the room dad dad dad yeah yeah and
they were ripping me apart and i'm
friends with i love all of them but um
and i left i go i'm never gonna do that
again but the next year i had to go back
because i had to celtic because i wasn't
selling tickets i had to do open anthony
but this time i said you know what i'm
gonna see the darkest
most fucked up shit about myself i'm
gonna make shit up i'm gonna lie i'm
gonna do all
all this shit right and that's
where i learned how to do all that i got
you know before they could even rip into
i was molested by a guy with down
syndrome you know man just my dad used
to beat him with golf club and just
constant constant you know i mean
because no i mean that's implied no one
without down syndrome would have
molested you no that is true i know
what do you mean a guy with down to
because he's what do you mean by that
only someone down syndrome would find
you attractive as a child
i'm just saying it's obvious that the
person at down syndrome
i mean how dumb was i when you lure a
kid you have to offer them candy or
something
[Laughter]
he wasn't talking to last year
you
[Laughter]
do you feel like
you feel like though moving forward as
people that are trying to
better ourselves and still stay funny
you know i definitely get scared a lot
where i remember my therapist said to me
once it's lonely at the the emotionally
sober top you know because a lot of
people
you know are not going to be able to
understand boundaries they're going to
be whatever it is so i think there's a
little bit of me that was like i don't
want to get too well because number one
i'm not going to be able to be friends
with all these people that i tell people
did i like love and i don't wanna have
to like end friendship so i'm just gonna
stay sick in these areas so that i can
you know i'm gonna stay a doormat so i
cannot or i'm so afraid of having a
friendship breakup that i'm just gonna
stay sick and or when i see this person
i'm just gonna revert to that role
you know even though it's toxic or
abusive or whatever so i don't have to
end it
but number two if i get too well
what if i won't be funny anymore because
so much of what's funny is going i'm a
piece of shit and i suck and i you know
like
do you worry about it but if you but if
you rearrange because this podcast is
this the better we get the less funnier
we are i'm just telling you i know but
if you rearrange that thing that i gave
you the circles of intimacy or whatever
yeah
um if i rearrange it it's not as
it's not as important right
when everything is show business in your
career and this and that right
then it's like and you rearrange it it
it doesn't it's like oh whatever you can
i'm not as funny whatever yeah i'm i'm
happier i'm healthier and i'm gonna live
longer and
also this isn't
all this shit right here
isn't that real it's like it's all we
know what we're doing right right you
and i are different because you know you
and i can talk about real things i'm
talking about like when you have a comic
that's not i don't know and it's just
jokes we're making fun of people doesn't
that it's just it's entertainment right
but it's not
all of life right right all of like when
you go and see like
when you're hiking you can see it like a
bird land on a somebody's head or
whatever you go that's beautiful or
whatever well i would i would live
stream in a post-it yeah yeah but i mean
you see nature and you go you know and
you you ask i'm 50 when you turn 50 you
go
you know they say you know i think
socrates says a life not self-examined
is a life not worth living
and um
i guess they were doing self-help back
then yeah right and so
for me i've had to do a lot of
self-examining and i've just rearranged
things and
it seems to be
working like i don't i i don't have any
auditions right now did you say you saw
a bird land on someone's head are we
just gonna skip i wanted to skip by that
because i don't know how birds behave
and i just made that like a squirrel
yeah it's a squirrel better i just i i
just i feel like to just let that slide
i wanted to let it go once i said i'm
like did that never happens okay yeah
right but then i you're asking did you
see a vulture attack and just stand by
and not help that person
let me ask you this then
nowhere in history a bird has landed on
a fucking guy's head
i'm sure it has but you're just trying
to um yeah i i this is like a um
this is a i was telling the story the
other day that uh this super famous
person at snl once was trying to
that spade that no that tom cruise was
at snl and he was he's not gonna hire me
uh yeah i'm too tall i've just come to
terms with that all the actors that i'm
taller than are never going to hire me
and it's fine and that's the only reason
tom cruise won't hire me
because of my height that's what i'll
tell myself and he was trying to just
like um
attune to the writers and like hang out
with them and like just be one of them
and he was just doing small talk and
they were like what's it like to be tom
cruise and he just went you know
i i wish i just had regular problems
like everybody else like he was married
to katie holmes at the time and he was
like i wish that katie would come home
someday and just be like ah i don't know
what to do for dinner they ran out of
ravioli at the ravioli store
so like in the jokes like he thinks
there's a ravioli store
that's how far gone
yeah he it which is fascinating to me
because i'm like maybe the places he
does go out which are like
like fancy towns in italy they might
have a ravioli store yeah he that might
be his truth or the other way to look at
that is that everyone that works for him
in order to like stay employed have uh
gaslit him into believing there's like a
store for every food so that like if he
knew there was whole foods
like you would there he'd have way less
people on staff yeah so they're like we
have to go to the ravioli store we have
to go to the eggplant store then we have
to head down to the candle store like
they like it's just been crazy i'm gonna
have to do overtime yeah okay but so the
fact that you think birds just land on
people's heads i guess i was like has he
ever been on a highway has you ever seen
a bird in the wild maybe you've been in
the movie business too were you at
animal practice
don't make fun of don't fucking career
shame don't when you why because of the
monkey when when someone when when when
someone's been on a tv show where they
were trained animals they have no idea
how real animals behave
connected so i did the pilot you know
the russo brothers directed uh
predicting animal practice was on nbc
and it was a bunch of animal it was
about a few years
i would play the veterinarian and so for
the pilot you know the russo brothers
are show running and they did all the
avengers movies all that stuff right and
they go we're going to put a um boa
constructor so we're just going to do a
pan of what people are doing in their
like right so they panned by me and a
constructor is strangling which is very
funny very funny right but what they
didn't realize they were jerking off
yeah what they didn't realize is that
sometimes every once in a while a bow
constrictor even the the show business
ones
they will exude a poison through their
skin
right
so the fucking bone constructions are on
my neck
the camera is going by and they go god
and there was these fucking boils
on my head and i started shaking
there it was an emergency they took the
fucking ball and i fell on the ground
right and that's what that mark is on
your
and that's what this motherfucker
no no um
and then i went to the hospital
i had an allergic reaction that anyway i
don't know why i love going for
hollywood is so fucked up i love people
going from a fake hospital to soundstage
getting injured in a fake hospital then
it's like we got to take him to a real
hospital it's like that's so fascinating
to me but yeah it's funny when like when
i'm around like hollywood actors and
they like are around like dogs or pup
they'll just they'll just like handle
them in ways or i'm like no okay you've
been on t you've been in too many movies
or like movies like like i have a friend
who like because everyone wants to do
equine therapy with me now
because they see what i do with my horse
and i talk about how much has helped me
and like i'll have friends that they'll
just like come in and they'll be like oh
i'm just gonna jump on that horse i'm
like no no like like
that's what you did in a movie you can't
just jump on a horse yeah in real you
had nine hands
this isn't saddle ranch you can't just
jump on a bunking bronco whenever you
want but that reminds me of this story
that i i i have been told this story
from people in the exotic animal world
um that uh uh that have there was this
woman that was keeping a snake as a pet
i i don't think it was a boat it might
have been a boa constrictor because you
can keep them as pets and if you raise
them from being babies you can actually
have them as a pet and you feed them
eggs and rats and stuff like that and
this woman had a boa constrictor because
someone because there's all these exotic
animals that were in movies that we now
can't use animals in movies anymore nor
should you it's always abuse but that
means there's all these exotic animals
that are like out of work basically yeah
that need to be rescued or that they're
using at like kids birthday parties and
abusing them in other ways because it's
expensive to keep a fucking elephant but
you can't use them in movies anymore
because it's abuse so
all these like l.a weirdo animal
trainers have a bunch of exotic animals
and no way to pay for them so they're
doing all this other fucked up shit
right so or trying to get them rescued
so this this this exotic animal chair in
l.a was like i've got a couple snakes
would you rescue them and i'm like how
do i rescue a snake like what the fuck
does that look like i don't wanna uh uh
like and then i'm like looking into it
and i and i watch this video and it's
about you know when you see on youtube
all these like weird pairings of like a
bird and an elephant or best friends and
a coyote and otter like all these just
like little
things that are really cute do you know
what i'm talking about
yeah you know and then there's the guy
that lives with the hyenas like on
youtube you can you know and so i'm
looking at this girl she's got a bow
constrictor that she's raised as a pet
and they fully are like
buddies like she's got the snake and
they go to the grocery store together
and they sleep together and the snake
really seems to like know her and she
feeds it like rat eggs or whatever the
fuck and i'm like oh my
you know you can you can
anthropomorphize anything you can
project i'm like this snake like loves
this woman i'm like
am i projecting or is this real and as
we were talking about before with you
and the cows and the pigs you just
discovered at 50 that that pigs and cows
like
like people that feed them uh it was
very sweet to watch
and
you're like cows will come up to you if
they know you
because when you're an eat meat eater
your whole life you you're in complete
the night you don't even that's right
you have to look you have to be you have
to be so there are there are the ability
if you raise something from birth to
have a real connection with it i'm like
oh my god this girl has this connection
with this bow constrictor but then it
gets sick and it's not eating and that's
the first thing if a dog doesn't eat
it's sick something's wrong with it she
takes it to
the uh the exotic animal vat and the
exotic animal vet goes um your bow
constrictor is fine what it's doing is
saving up space in its stomach to eat
you
so what happens is boa constrictors will
starve themselves to stretch their
stomachs big enough to fit the their
prey
so it's been sleeping with you every
night and it's starving itself so that
it can swallow you whole
and she's like my snake's not eating
it must be sick
fucking insane wild that is fucking wild
and that crazy i want to blow people's
mind too
the monkey on animal practice got
sixteen thousand dollars an episode wait
is that the monkey that chris extra
takes chris over june yeah yeah so june
diane rachel was on the podcast
the actors would get like one take and
then the ostrich would get like 15 takes
crystal the monkey ran that set yeah
yeah crystal on mine right yeah
it was not even on him crystal the
monkey who was in the hangover she's a
famous crystal wasn't even it was my
coverage
right
and i'm like and it's a big chunk of
line so i'm like oh my god i don't know
how i'm gonna get to this monologue
right and i'm almost at the end they go
cut i go what's the matter nigga
crystal's playing with itself and chris
was like
[Music]
[Laughter]
maybe you turned her on
i wrote something down because i don't
want to forget let's just forget let's
just first let's forget this whole thing
happened yeah um no let's just anything
that was outstanding i'm actually trying
to make a coherent podcast believe it or
not you didn't finish the third circle
of your uh
intimacy anus so oh the other circles of
intimacy okay so um
your fam your family goes in here you
know your girlfriend your wife goes here
and your family
okay but okay so for people just
listening the middle circle you're
saying family however family life what
the fuck
i'm just saying you're people are go for
runs they do laundry while they're
listening to podcasts and you're just
referring to something no one knows what
you're referring to
imagine if you're listening to this and
someone just said family goes here
goes where yeah but you just two minutes
ago you we talked about the circles
you're pointing to something people
can't see all right so i have the
circles okay only i have the fucking
circles of intimacy right and you asked
me what
so the middle one should be god and
yourself spirituality okay the second
one your wife or you know i mean your
significant chosen yes your third one
family and whatnot and family if they're
not toxic and horrible right okay and
sometimes
people have their careers in there but
for me
career is fourth now okay right and so
um it seems to is that a choice that was
made by casting directors or you
they put me eighth
i choose to put my career last year
i'm totally my choice
um
which is so is weird to me bobby because
you are like the hottest you've ever
been career-wise is it because not only
this all happened but now that you
are working a lot in non-stop
now you're like okay i got what i needed
i feel validated no okay what i realized
is that it wasn't fixing me yeah it
wasn't it doesn't work it was making me
crazier it you know it also didn't
feel i mean there were some projects i
did because
it's going to be good optically for me
and it was a fine experience but it just
didn't do anything it would break my
heart though actually like when i would
see you and you would be in something
like a huge movie like an adam sandler
movie i'm like dude i just saw you that
i'm saying would be like shut up just
don't fuck you like i know what it's
like to be a part of something and and
then be embarrassed because then you're
like oh no everyone's just gonna see how
how uh
bad i looked or how
not i wasn't the star of that thing it's
almost like
a lot of people see something that
you're not proud of it's almost worse
than never having booked it at all or
gotten the job at all oh yeah i've been
in a couple of years yeah that were
embarrassing to me or you signed up for
a really big part and it got cut down
and you're just like ugh like this is
like or you get completely cut out of a
movie that's the worst
you know i mean i took my like dad
before he died to a movie premiere of a
movie that i was like had like eight
scenes in and i it literally was like
can i take your order like it was like i
had like one line
it was
so embarrassing so and i was like
talking to the publicist being like can
i get five tickets like i was like i was
like fighting to get they had seen the
final cut and fully knew i'd been cut
out of the entire thing no one told me
no one tells you ahead of time don't fly
in your friends and family
to see this that happened to me
four months five months ago
i literally just went after tom cruise i
feel like i feel like all events are up
all right so
four years ago three years ago i get a
call
from this director and he's like hey man
i'm doing this gigantic sony animation
movie it's on all asian cast
i want you jackie chan john chu just
right but you would be one of the main
guys this and that and i go
let me read it i read it it's an
animation i don't know much about
animation movies so i just did it
and um
i worked on it for years you know how
you just movie sometimes an animation of
course keep going takes forever a year
later they're like come in do another
session
so i worked on it and then i saw
i don't know
so the
i i was you know you're watching youtube
and they do an ad of a movie so it's
coming out it was one of those ads you
could skip but i watched it
and at the end of it it goes staring
jimmy oh yeah it's just eight names
right i'm not in it but then and then
you look at the title n sequence and you
you know the directed by all the things
and i read there was like 15 names in
there my name wasn't on there right yeah
so i call my guy my agent i go oh
next time just tell me when i'm cut out
of something uh-huh they're like you're
not cut out of it
they confused you with no
another asian person
they thought they don't they think
you're johnny bobby with the same people
yeah gemma chan we're here
yeah um so um
i go well i'm not and they go
we don't know why
and this is the first time
i made phone calls
to
everyone
because normally i would let it go
mm-hmm and not fight for myself it's
disrespectful and disrespectful just
tell me i'm an adult and
and i called
the ne the netflix
sony made it i called sony
and they were just oh
yeah you know i mean they just didn't
know and they
they apologized profusely this and that
but i had to express
my resent not my resentment just
confusion and just clear this up man or
just like my thing is more like we're
adults you know what i'm saying like
it's sort of like people treat us like
we're these children that can't be told
anything i remember i did um
animation is so weird the first
animation thing i got was for planes
remember planes great movies but i i was
the i was a
plane that was like the sexy plane
and
[Laughter]
i went
not the pitchy plane i'm not the bitch
but i'm not for some reason and i go to
the um
table read and i'm it's like tj miller
it's all the people that get every
single job do you know what i mean right
and i'm like the sexy plane i'm like
very and she's very like that she's like
i'm like i don't know how to act like a
sexy
i'm just gonna do me i'm just like hey
what do you guys do because in my head
like sexy doesn't have to be like this
like
it just was like i was like this is for
children it's shaped like a dick did you
get fired it was uh not only did i get
fired
oh no not only did i get fired but the
note was like well she wasn't sexy and
not she wasn't doing a sexy enough voice
and it was a it was like a black jet and
i was like this is in the shape of a
black flying dick and i have to be like
hey big boy isn't this for children yeah
yeah and i remember just being like i am
do not know how to do animation yeah but
you know what this is another thing i
used to do is until one time it was a
disaster so
is to ask
before yeah yeah i mean like one time i
was at a table read and i said shit take
it just it was written in the shit tank
right and afterwards like um that's
shiitake dude
and i go i and i knew because written
weird yes right and i should have asked
yes can i tell you so this really
happened and this is where i asked and
if i didn't ask i would have been fucked
all right
so i'm in a movie called borderlands
coming out okay it was like um it was a
obviously the table wasn't zoom right
sure everyone's around the world and so
my i had to be there like six in the
morning saturday morning because it was
at a certain time in hungary certain
time in other europeans you know right
so i had to get up early to do it and
but before a week before
the director eli roth who's one of the
greatest direct you know eli i love eli
and i i can't wait to see you again eli
i love you one of the best directors
i've ever worked so nice he's a genius
he's a genius
so but a week before his a sit and go
listen we don't we haven't cast the
whole thing
so you have to read all these other
parts
so he's like you have to play the
villain the main villain we haven't cast
that out you know i mean and he gave me
probably 20 parts so i spent all week
literally memorizing because i didn't
want to fuck up because i've never been
in a table read with jack black and
fucking cape blanchett right right right
so i'm writing all of it down oh that's
right you're in that giant movie yeah so
five minutes before we do this gigantic
title
table read
there's so many boxes of actors i don't
know yeah and i just had this gut
feeling
and i called the assistant i go are you
sure i'm reading all these parts he goes
oh no you're just reading your part now
but if i hadn't done that i would have
talked over kate blanchet
i would have talked over other actors
and then they would have to stop and go
what the fuck are you doing i go well
then uh but your assistant said that you
have to read all you know i mean but you
it's always important to go
i'm asian it's our time
stop check your block you're out allie
wong get it
[Applause]
i'm a crazy rich asian i do whatever the
fuck i want yeah i mean
audition for that this is why i could
not get an audition for that
couldn't get an audition for hangover
couldn't get an audition for any age
they just did a book on they just did a
fuck
they just did a fucking book on asians
in pop culture sure not a
mention of my oh but that's that's also
not like they'll do like a documentary
on like women in comedy and it'll come
out and i'm like
okay
[Music]
you're like cool
it's like i'm not even gonna spend time
taking this personally because i
probably wouldn't want to do it anyway
like it's just the kind of thing where
you're like do you want to be right
but you should oh that my point is is
that i'd rather just being a documentary
about comedians you would rather just be
you should have gone to planes you
should gone to the table read went to
the writer or one of the producers no i
just go listen i was gonna play it like
this but what do you how do you guys
think i should play it yeah but i'm
given the fact that this is a children's
movie and it's weird to make a plane
sexy
why don't i just be funny instead you
fucking weirdo okay but instead of
making a grand choice like that
all right daniel day-lewis but here's i
guess
i guess
i guess the thing is about me that that
i i do trust me i i
i am at the risk of seeming like a
psycho a diva i i will ask 50 times i'm
just confirming double confirming triple
confirming i just want to make sure i
get this right and then as a woman
though you only have a couple you had to
ask like three or four questions before
you're difficult or you're annoying or
you're
a hassle
so i always feel like i have to be like
is there anything i need to know
pl like please tell me if i'm doing
something wrong you know i can do this
and if i do it wrong it's your fault
yeah
it's your fault you haven't been clear
okay but i think a lot of people are
afraid to tell people how to do
something because they don't want to get
accused of like rape anymore so no one
will tell me
what's happening
i go on a movie and no one will even
talk to me they're so afraid that
they're like i'm gonna call ron and
pharaoh i'm like can someone tell me
what to do and they're like you just do
whatever you want whatever makes you
comfortable we want to make a safe space
and i'm like well can someone tell me
where to stand and they're like wherever
you want to stand i'm like
you guys can't be so afraid to direct
actors that i have no clue what's
happening but people but here's the
thing
just don't rape me but i i know but when
you're acting right what people
sometimes don't realize is you're a
comedian as well yeah right and so this
actually happened i wasn't hungry and
i don't want to drop names can i drop a
name well you already said kate
blanchett all right jamie curtis
the woman from the activia commercial
yeah yeah she goes um
hey um
this is literally okay i fly to hungary
i'm scared shitless like i'm like don't
fuck this opportunity up
i knew my lines way before you know i
mean i'm like don't fuck it up so i go
to the hotel thing to replace you with
everyone from crazy just fast
they're working on the sequel
you're sort of a fucking i'm sorry i
miss having comedians
so sh uh so i go to my hotel room and
there's a letter
on my bed sure with jamie lee curtis on
top of the this letter heading
she's like hey i don't know you but um
welcome to the movie she's the best and
she goes um tomorrow let's have
lunch i go fuck yeah right i meet her
for lunch but there's other actors a
talented actor by the name of cheyenne
jackson
love amazing singer too singer dancer
he's everything right so it's me
cheyenne and um
penn from penn teller
i think you say bagley but okay yeah
yeah so um
she we have lunch and she goes i want to
take you to the river and so along this
river in hungary are all these bronze
shoes
right and that was back in 1945 or
whatever when
um germany went in there and they just
shot a bunch of hungarian jews and threw
them in the river
right and it's a solemn place
you don't tell jokes sure
me too
i just why are they bronze so they're
like you guys got third place
i would see if you were with me i would
have been safe right
so i i don't say anything
and then cheyenne jackson goes oh
these little shoes are little
it was a boy
right a little boy everyone's emotional
and i go
it could have been a midget
and they all turn around and they walk
away so i'm staring at these bronze
shoes going
those would fit me
yeah yeah but going oh i'm off this
movie this is terrible
why
why no one would think that was funnier
than eli ross
right but my point is is that sometimes
it's like you know they don't know
you're a comedian yeah yeah right and
you're they just think that you're an
actor they don't know anything about me
you know
they're not tiger belly bad friend
friends but my point is is that you know
so sometimes you know um
you have to turn that off
yes we're straight we should do this
more often i feel like you i think we
should do this more often on camera or
off in general both i do too but here's
what i'll say i feel like i i'm now
going to adjust to the new bobby because
i've spent a lot of time going just
don't smother him don't pressure him
but now that you don't watch porn i feel
like you have a lot more time
on your hands to hang out
i feel like it just freed up eight or
nine hours a day for you to have
it's really hard to friendships with
equals is the key to sanity i am
learning for that is not work always
it's nice to be in your 20 million
dollar house
wait you just turned around once you
have to do it twice more that's not a
movie theater okay okay
that's well that's the question i want
to ask you real quick fuck it right i
thought you had to you kept saying
marvel and working work is your dream to
be in big movies
um your bigger dreams that you have
where you're at now if they are fun and
like with amazing people
uh there's nothing more fun so like
doing the foo fighters movie i just did
the machine gun kelly movie can i say
something about david grohl sure
he did mad tv i try to meet him i'm the
biggest i saw nirvana play wow i know i
have every foo fighters album yeah right
and i just can't get him to even know i
exist
just tell him about me
second thing is is this right do you
have entitlement i'm writing that down
tell girl tell dave yeah let me just
remember can someone remind me grace can
you remind me to tell
dave i'm just the biggest fucking fan
like i would suck
i will suck that is on the top of my
list yeah so
i know what you're doing
do you have entitlement issues
yes
like in terms of i believe i should be
able to pee right now
yeah and not answer this question or
we'll we'll ask this later yeah because
it's a whole thing yeah i gotta get the
fuck out of here it's too long yes and
i'm saying my entitlement stuff is not
about like i'm entitled to i think when
you work as hard as you and i work yeah
we go we're entitled we deserve this
thing but we're in a business that is is
is your success is a confluence of hard
work and some luck and a lot of other
things yeah so are there places that
trigger you
places that trigger me but you're
entitlement because i have two places
that do oh that's interesting yeah yeah
uh
you you go first so i understand the
question so um my thing is restaurants
all right so here's what i do in
restaurants okay okay
hi i don't have a roast like i went to
this place called houston's in
scottsdale i love houston's right and i
go um
this is so embarrassing but i have to
talk about it
i was there at five not busy i go i
don't have a reservation but can i get a
seat it's a 45-minute wait by the way
houston's that's actually short for
houston's
okay
five o'clock on a thursday
in phoenix yeah that's when everyone
eats yeah but you know i know my eyes
are a little smaller than yours but i
have i can see
i can see the people in the restaurant
correct right
and my observation is they're not
slammed because i used to work at
restaurants but also are we in a
pandemic and they can't take as many
people
but that's not the thing
they were sitting
they sat 30 white people that walked in
you think it was personal i don't know
what it was personal but my mind says
that right so then i got you know what
no
so i was so embarrassing i walk up to
the hostess i go
do you guys have a twitter handle and i
had my twit tweet out
with my verified this and that and i
feel like the host just really deserved
this and
just listen sorry and she goes
come in and they gave me a table right
because you threaten them yeah so my
point is is this do you have any
instances like that where it triggers
you so for me from now on what i'm going
to do and what i've been doing is i know
when i go to a restaurant that i i'm
going to get triggered
so if that happens i just step outside
for five minutes and i just think it
through i breathe and yeah
you take things per i know what you mean
mine is probably like an example i could
probably think of many more
i
get triggered when i'm in
you know what i'm sorry that i'm saying
this and i'm not i don't mean this to be
against you but when i am in a public
place and someone loses their temper of
people that have no control over the
situation like when someone
goes up to a hostess and is like
why i don't deserve to wait like
everybody knows
when i am at the like jet blue counter
and someone's screaming at the jet blue
person who has absolutely no control
over whether the plane's cancelled or
yeah yeah i i am like can you stop
yelling at this person that's not
entitlement i know but i i i i we're
talking about a completely different
fucking thing right now when i'm at my
house and people that i invited my home
as a guest leave their saliva covered
toothpicks all over my brand new table
okay okay definitely okay i definitely
feel entitled
like maybe they could respect really
good
okay no i think for me it's it's when i
take things personally that are not
personal a lot of times it's when people
like don't use coasters and look at the
amount of coasters i have out and i've
just
i've i've dropped it right
it's not everyone else's job to to
accommodate that i just have to drop it
because my scarcity complex growing up
sometimes i'm friends with comics that
are like very rain man like yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's a little weird as well
let's fucking end it
don't write elephants
i love you now you're 37 days over
that's really funny
[Music]
wow
[Applause]